I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, Angela. Hi there.
我是詹娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了这个终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。你好，安吉拉。你好呀。
Hi everyone. That's right. We have an exciting episode today. I'm excited about our episode today. I am too. I'm looking at our desk right now and you guys, there's all kinds of packages. There's stuff. There's chashkis.
大家好。没错。我们今天有一集非常精彩的节目。我对我们今天的节目很兴奋。我也是。我正看着我们的桌子，你们看，各种包裹都有。有东西。还有小摆设。
There's nicotinex. I can't wait. What did we bring? Well, today is our mailbag episode. We went through all of our mail again, both digital and, what would you call it, real? Physical. Physical. Yeah, we opened it.
还有戒烟贴。我已经等不及了。我们带来了什么？好吧，今天是我们的听众来信环节。我们再次整理了所有的来信，包括电子版和，你会怎么称呼它，真实的？实体版。实体版的。对，我们打开了它们。
We're going to share all about it. And I even have a couple of great deep dives. I was not expecting a deep dive today. I know you weren't, but you'll see, it's a good time. Well, let's start with some Office Ladies news. I like that, Angela, because we do have some news. Go first. All right.
我们将分享关于这一切的一切。我甚至准备了几个精彩的深度剖析。我没想到今天会有深度剖析。我知道你没想到，但你会看到的，这会很有趣。好吧，让我们从一些“办公室女士”的新闻开始吧。我喜欢这样，安吉拉，因为我们确实有一些新闻。你先说。好的。
Office Ladies news number one on January 4th. To kick off the new year, we will be having a special, special guest on our podcast, Billy Eilish. Yes, OMG. Billy came into the studio and sat with us, and we gabbed and gabbed and gabbed all about her love of the office. We fully geeked out in front of her, but she was so charming and sweet. And we met her mom, Maggie, who was so delightful.
“办公室女士”新闻第一条：1月4日。为了开启新的一年，我们的播客将迎来一位特别特别的嘉宾，比利·艾利什。是的，天呐。比利来到录音室和我们坐在一起，我们聊呀聊呀聊，全都是关于她对《办公室》的喜爱。我们在她面前彻底化身狂热粉丝，但她非常迷人和甜美。我们还见到了她的妈妈玛吉，她非常讨人喜欢。
You know, Jenna, we were chatting with Maggie, and I thought she looked familiar. And then she said she was main company at the Groundlings Theater. You guys know us. Yes. And this is where you can learn sketch comedy and improv. There's theater and a school. I was there. I think we crossed paths at the Groundlings.
你知道，詹娜，我们和玛吉聊天时，我觉得她看起来很面熟。然后她说她是格劳宁斯剧院（Groundlings Theater）的主演。你们了解我们。是的。这就是你可以学习小品喜剧和即兴表演的地方。那里有剧院和学校。我去过。我想我们在格劳宁斯剧院有过交集。
That's amazing. I went back and I looked up and I found a sketch with her and Will Ferrell. It's on YouTube. It is so hilarious. They're on the Groundlings stage and they're pretending to be members of a high school marching band. And she is playing the flute. Really playing it.
太棒了。我回去查了一下，找到了一段她和威尔·法瑞尔的小品。在YouTube上。太搞笑了。他们在格劳宁斯的舞台上，假装是高中行进乐队的成员。她在吹长笛。真的在吹。
He's playing the saxophone, but then they're having this awkward adolescence conversation. I'll put it in our stories. Maggie was hilarious. Well, here's something crazy. After the interview, we're standing in the hallway and Billy says, you know, my mom was on an episode of The Office. You and I about pooped our pants. We're like, what?
他在吹萨克斯，然后他们进行了一场尴尬的青春期对话。我会把它发到我们的快拍里。玛吉太搞笑了。好吧，这里有一件疯狂的事。采访结束后，我们站在走廊里，比利说，你知道，我妈妈曾客串过一集《办公室》。你和我当时差点吓尿。我们当时想，什么？
What? We were like, what? And she said, well, my mom was also a voice actress and her voice is on The Office. And then it turns out that she was in Goodbye, Toby, part one. Remember that's the episode where Michael wants to throw an elaborate party for Toby's Goodbye. He puts Phyllis in charge. He tells her he wants an anti-gravity machine.
什么？我们当时想，什么？她说，嗯，我妈妈还是一名配音演员，她的声音出现在《办公室》里。后来发现，她出现在了《告别托比（上集）》中。还记得那是迈克尔想为托比的告别办一场精心派对的那集吗？他让菲利斯负责。他告诉她他想要一台反重力机器。
So she's making phone calls. When we listened to the episode, we weren't sure who was on the other line. We asked Kentopedia. He thought it was this one actress who's this great character actress, but he couldn't be sure. Well, now we know. I found an audio clip. This is Billy Eilish's mom, Maggie Baird.
所以她在打电话。当我们听这一集时，我们不确定电话那头是谁。我们问了肯托百科（Kentopedia）。他以为是某个伟大的性格女演员，但他无法确定。好吧，现在我们知道了。我找到了一段音频剪辑。这是比利·艾利什的妈妈，玛吉·拜尔德。
Hi. Are there any local companies that rent anti-gravity machines? Anti-gravity machines? That's right. Yeah. What do they do exactly? They make you feel lighter. Anti-gravity.
你好。请问有当地的公司出租反重力机器吗？反重力机器？没。对。它们到底是干什么的？它们能让你感觉更轻盈。反重力。
Anti-depressant. I could put you through to someone on that. Okay. Yay. It's so good. Well, we were also reminiscing about the time that I met Billy and her mom, Maggie, at the San Francisco airport years ago. Billy was a fan of the office and had asked me for a photo.
抗抑郁药。我可以帮你转接负责这个的人。好的。太棒了。太棒了。好吧，我们还在回忆多年前我在旧金山机场遇到比利和她妈妈玛吉的那次。比利是《办公室》的粉丝，曾向我索要一张照片。
And as we were talking about this moment, Maggie was like, Angela, I remember when Billy asked for your photo, you were really excited because you had just bought a jacket and a vending machine at the airport. It was insane. It was insane to find out that Angela had gone on and on about her vending machine jacket. To a stranger. Yeah. I had just met.
当我们谈到这一刻时，玛吉说，安吉拉，我记得当比利向你要照片时，你真的超级兴奋，因为你刚刚在机场的自动售货机上买了一件夹克。这太疯狂了。得知安吉拉一直在喋喋不休地谈论她的售货机夹克，这太疯狂了。对一个陌生人。是的。我刚认识的。
But that tracks, that's you. That's me. And she said you were really excited because you'd only paid $60 for it. I can't believe she remembered that detail. Well, guys, we cannot wait for you to hear this conversation that we had with Billy all about her love of the office. She asked us questions. We asked her questions.
但这很符合你的风格，这就是你。这就是我。她说你当时真的很兴奋，因为你只花60美元就买下了它。我简直不敢相信她还记得这个细节。好吧，伙计们，我们迫不及待地想让你们听到这段我们与比利关于她对《办公室》的热爱的对话。她问我们问题。我们问她问题。
Again, that's going to air on January 4th. And then the following week, we're going to be breaking down threat level midnight with BJ Novak. What a fun way to kick off 2023. I know. I agree with you. We're excited about it. Yes.
再说一次，这将于1月4日播出。然后在接下来的一周，我们将与B·J·诺瓦克一起剖析《危机重重：午夜》。这是开启2023年的多么有趣的方式啊。我知道。我同意你的看法。我们对此很兴奋。是的。
We're excited about it. We're excited about office ladies news. Number two is that we are finally going on the road. Boo boo. Boo boo. Hey, you did my thing. I did your part. We are going to be at the just for laughs festival in Vancouver, Canada on February 24th.
我们对此很兴奋。我们对“办公室女士”新闻感到兴奋。第二条是我们要终于要上路巡演啦。嘘——！嘘——！嘿，你抢了我的台词。我代劳了。我们将于2月24日参加在加拿大温哥华举办的“不羁喜剧节”（Just for Laughs festival）。
It's an evening with office ladies. We are so excited. Tickets are on sale now 2023. We're going to be on the road. Yes. We are hoping that that is our year that we can finally hit the road and come out and see you all. This is going to be the first one.
这是一场“办公室女士”之夜。我们太兴奋了。门票现已开售，2023年。我们要上路了。是的。我们希望那是我们终于可以上路巡演并出来见见大家的一年。这将是第一场。
We hope it goes well. Yeah. We hope. You know, we had so much fun in New York at town hall. We really did. That was such a great evening. It really inspired us to do more. So 2023.
我们希望一切顺利。是的。我们希望如此。你知道，我们在纽约市政厅玩得太开心了。真的非常开心。那真是一个美好的夜晚。这真的启发了我们去做更多。所以，2023年。
Tickets are on sale now for the just for laughs festival. We'll put a link in our office ladies pod on Instagram. Office ladies news. Number three, a lot of you have reached out to me and you know, I do the stories on office ladies pod and you've said, and I missed the stories. I got home late from work and now they're all gone. And we've been talking about what are ways where we can always make the stories available. And then Jenna was like, oh, and we could make highlights out of them.
“不羁喜剧节”的门票现已开售。我们会在Instagram的office ladies pod上发布链接。“办公室女士”新闻第三条，你们很多人联系过我，你知道的，我在office ladies pod上做快拍，你们说，我错过了快拍。我下班回家晚了，现在它们全都没了。我们一直在讨论有什么方法能让快拍一直可用。然后詹娜就说，哦，我们可以把它们做成精选（Highlights）。
I was like, well, crap. To be fair, that was an email that I found in our email box. It wasn't my idea. So yes, it took you all writing in about it for us to realize that we could make highlights of our stories. I don't know why we didn't think of it. I feel so silly. Ladies who run an Instagram.
我当时想，好吧，废话。公平地说，那是我在收件箱里发现的一封电子邮件。那不是我的主意。所以，是的，正是因为你们写信来，我们才意识到我们可以把快拍做成精选。我不知道为什么我们之前没想到。我觉得自己太傻了。经营Instagram的女士们。
I know. I know. I know we are. It's not a high tech machine here. So I went into our stories and as it turns out, there was about a year and a half there of stories. Amazing. It took me a few days and I finally got all the episodes that were still there in little
我知道。我知道。我知道我们是。这里可没有什么高科技机器。所以我查看了我们的快拍，结果发现那里大约有一年半的快拍内容。太神奇了。我花了几天时间，终于把所有还在那里的剧集都做成了小小的
highlights. So you'll see them on office ladies pod. I worked one day so long on it that my phone got really hot and I couldn't hold my phone. I was like, this is probably bad, but they're there you guys and I hope you enjoy them. And it was really fun. I kind of just got to go down memory lane of our last two years. Well you work so hard on those every week, Angela, and it always bothered me that they were gone in 24 hours because a lot of people listen to the podcast later in the week.
精选。所以你们会在office ladies pod上看到它们。我有一天在上面工作了太久，以至于我的手机变得非常烫，我都拿不住手机了。我当时想，这可能不太好，但它们就在那里，伙计们，希望你们喜欢。这真的很有趣。我简直就像是重温了我们过去两年的记忆。好吧，安吉拉，你每周都在这些上面付出那么多努力，而我总是对它们在24小时后消失感到耿耿于怀，因为很多人会在一周晚些时候才听播客。
So now, if you listen to the podcast on a weekly basis, you'll have a little highlighted story that coordinates with each episode. Thanks to Angela. You're welcome. I do have one note for the people that run Instagram. Yes. The little title for each highlight, you only give me like nine characters. I know.
所以现在，如果你每周都听播客，你就会有一个与每集相对应的小精选快拍。多亏了安吉拉。不客气。我确实给经营Instagram的人有一个意见。是的。每个精选的小标题，你只给我大约九个字符。我知道。
Maybe 10. So like, for example, the episode, the manager and the salesman, you can't fit that. So if you guys go, I don't, I can't remember, I think I put manager slash, I don't, I can't remember. Man sale. Man sale. So if you go and look at the titles and you're like, that's weird, like classy Xmas. It's because I didn't have a lot of room.
也许10个。所以，比如，某一集《经理与推销员》，你根本放不下。所以如果你去看看，我记不太清了，我想我写的是“经理斜杠”，我记不太清了。经理推销。经理推销。所以如果你去看那些标题，觉得“真奇怪，比如‘高档圣诞’”，那是因为我没有太多空间。
That's what she said. One other tiny piece of news before we go to break, we are moving studios. We have to leave these ear wolf studios. We're real bummed about it. Yeah. The lease is up in this space and the powers that be decided not to renew. So we are on the lookout for a new space. We're going around looking up spaces and we'll let you know when we find our new home.
这话她说的。在进入休息之前还有一条小新闻，我们要搬工作室了。我们必须离开这个耳狼（Earwolf）工作室了。我们对此真的很沮丧。是的。这里的租期到了，当权者决定不续租。所以我们正在寻找新的空间。我们到处去看场地，等我们找到新家时会通知大家的。
We're being very picky because we basically just want a space that looks exactly like this space. We moved into one place last week and we were like, well, the table is not the same. The chairs are not the same. There aren't enough lamps for Angela. I actually asked Josh if he could help us move this table when we move. I know. We're like, well, what's happening to this stuff?
我们非常挑剔，因为我们基本上只是想要一个看起来和这个空间一模一样的空间。我们上周去看了一个地方，然后我们想，嗯，桌子不一样。椅子不一样。安吉拉的灯不够多。我甚至问乔什，我们搬家时能不能帮我们搬这张桌子。我知道。我们当时想，那这些东西怎么办？
Let's just move it all. Gosh, we don't like change. Do we? We're not good at it. We're not good at it. You know what? Don't give me a new remote. I don't want your new stinkin remote.
索性全搬走吧。天哪，我们不喜欢改变。对吧？我们不擅长这个。我们不擅长这个。你知道吗？别给我一个新的遥控器。我才不要你那该死的新遥控器呢。
I just got used to the one remote I have. This sounds like. That's how I feel about this move. Something that happened in real life. Well, maybe. Got a new remote. You know what? I don't want your dumb computer update.
我刚习惯了我现在用的这一个遥控器。听起来像。这就是我对这次搬家的感觉。发生在现实生活中的事。也许吧。拿到一个新遥控器。你知道吗？我才不要你那愚蠢的电脑更新。
Oh, don't give it to me. Not interested. Go away. Yeah. All right. Well, listen. Why don't we take a break and when we come back, I'm going to have a beverage. Oh, I have some sweet treats.
哦，别给我弄。不感兴趣。走开。是的。好吧，听着。我们为什么不休息一下，等我们回来，我要喝一杯。哦，我有一些甜点。
This is going to be good. And we're going to open up your mail and talk all about it. We are back. And like I said, I have a beverage to kick things off. You're being really sneaky about it because they're all in like a Starbucks cups, but you didn't get me a Starbucks. I did get you something at Starbucks. Okay.
这一定会很棒。然后我们要打开你们的信件并讨论一番。我们回来了。就像我说的，我准备了一杯饮料来拉开序幕。你对此鬼鬼祟祟的，因为它们都装在星巴克的杯子里，但你没有给我买星巴克。我确实在星巴克给你买东西了。好吧。
This is a non-alcoholic surprise. Okay. I know normally we go with a more adult beverage, but ever since the chair model episode, when Michael ordered a coffee while he was waiting to meet Pam's landlord, I have wanted to try Michael's drink. Oh Lord. Oh my God. It is a large hot chocolate with caramel and a shot of peppermint with whipped cream.
这是一个无酒精的惊喜。好吧。我知道通常我们会选择更成年人的饮料，但自从“椅子模特”那一集，迈克尔在等着见潘的房东时点了一杯咖啡开始，我就一直想尝试迈克尔的饮料。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。这是一杯大杯热巧克力，加焦糖、一泵薄荷糖浆和奶油。
And I got one for everyone. We've got Sam, Cassie, and Ainsley in studio today, guys. Come on in and grab your Michael's drink. Very scared, very excited. This is going to be like drinking a muffin. I thought it felt holiday with the peppermint shot. These were prepared by Evie. She's my gal that I always see at Starbucks.
我给每个人都买了一杯。今天在录音室里有萨姆、卡西和安斯利，伙计们。快进来拿你们的迈克尔特饮。非常害怕，非常兴奋。这感觉就像在喝一个松饼。我觉得加了薄荷糖浆很有节日的气氛。这些是伊芙（Evie）准备的。她是我在星巴克经常见到的那个女孩。
She was very excited to make these. She's a fan of the pod. Thank you, Evie. So, Evie, we're going to let you know how they are. Okay. Here we go. Here we go. I like it.
她做这些的时候非常兴奋。她是本播客的粉丝。谢谢你，伊芙。所以，伊芙，我们要让你知道它们味道如何。好吧。我们开始吧。我们开始吧。我喜欢。
I think it tastes good. It tastes like a chocolate covered, what's it called? Candy cane. I don't hate it. Or a York peppermint patty. It totally tastes like a York peppermint patty. These are great. Thank you.
我觉得味道很好。它尝起来像一块巧克力包裹的，叫什么来着？糖杖。我不讨厌它。或者像约克薄荷帕蒂巧克力（York peppermint patty）。它完全尝起来像约克薄荷帕蒂。这些太棒了。谢谢。
They're good. Sure. I'm telling you right now, I love the shot of peppermint, but I think I could make this into a hot toddy. And well, I will say we were gifted when Ainsley arrived, Ainsley brought everybody a cherry whiskey. Homemade. She made this, you guys.
很好喝。当然。我现在就告诉你，我很喜欢那一泵薄荷糖浆，但我觉得我可以把它变成热托迪酒（Hot Toddy）。而且，好吧，我要说的是，安斯利一到，我们就收到了一份礼物，安斯利给大家带来了樱桃威士忌。自制的。这是她做的，伙计们。
In a mason jar. In a mason jar. These are my favorite kind of gifts to get at the holidays. I love this. Should we try the whiskey? I had an idea because I'll say I'm really loving this coffee that's not a coffee that's really a hot chocolate. I'm loving it, but it is a little sweet for me and I'm also feeling disappointed that
装在梅森罐里。装在梅森罐里。这是我在节日里最喜欢收到的礼物。我太喜欢了。我们要尝尝威士忌吗？我有个主意，因为我要说的是，我真的很喜欢这杯其实不是咖啡、而是热巧克力的咖啡。我很喜欢，但对我来说有点甜，而且我也感到有点失望，因为
we aren't doing our usual sort of adult beverage at 10 AM. Ainsley, is there any cherry in that whiskey? They're actual cherries. Oh my God. Oh, there's cherries floating in here. Yes. There's cherries. Orange is good.
我们在早上10点没有喝我们惯常的那种成人饮料。安斯利，那威士忌里有樱桃吗？是真正的樱桃。哦，天哪。哦，里面漂浮着樱桃。是的。有樱桃。橙子很好。
Orange is good. A cinnamon stick and a touch of maple syrup. Oh my God. Oh, that is good. That is a hot toddy. Better than Michael's drink. All right. I'm going to say that, but I'm going to pour some of it into my...
橙子很好。还有一根肉桂棒和少许枫糖浆。哦，天哪。哦，那太棒了。那是热托迪酒。比迈克尔的饮料好喝。好吧。我要这么说，但我打算把一些倒进我的……
You are. You are? You are. We are. We are. Okay. I might have poured too much. No.
你会的。你会吗？你会的。我们会的。我们会的。好吧。我可能倒太多了。不。
How much did you pour? Too much. Maybe too much. Here it goes. I'm stirring. I should have stirred. Here we go. I'm going to try mine.
你倒了多少？太多了。可能太多了。开始吧。我在搅拌。我应该搅拌一下的。我们开始吧。我要尝尝我的。
Oh my God. That is delicious. That is, that is Christmas morning. Hello. Good morning, everybody. Good night. That is nice. That's nice.
哦，天哪。太美味了。那是，那是圣诞节的早晨。你好。大家早安。晚安。真不错。真不错。
Highly recommend. You know what? That sip did that thing where you fill it in the warm spot of your throat. It goes down. And then it settles in your belly and it starts a fire in the best way. Warms you up on a cold day. All right. Michael's coffee order with a splash of Ainsley's whiskey cherry.
强烈推荐。你知道吗？那一口产生了一种奇妙的感觉，它充满了你喉咙温暖的地方。它流了下去。然后它在你的胃里安定下来，以最好的方式点燃了一把火。在寒冷的日子里温暖你。好吧。迈克尔的咖啡点单加上一小撮安斯利的威士忌樱桃。
I've got more treats. More treats. I've got more treats. They are not beverages. They are little desserts. First of all, Josh and my kids made cookies for you guys last night. They're like a chocolate cookie with marshmallows on top. And then you crush peppermint candy.
我还有更多好吃的。更多好吃的。我还有更多好吃的。它们不是饮料。它们是小甜点。首先，乔什和我的孩子们昨晚为你们烤了饼干。它们有点像上面有棉花糖的巧克力饼干。然后你把薄荷糖敲碎。
It's like a hot cocoa cookie. So I brought those for everybody who wants one. How much sugar are we going to have today? The second half of this show is in math. I know. And then, okay, you guys here, come take a cookie. Okay. How are they guys?
就像热可可饼干。所以我为所有想要的人带了这些。我们今天到底要摄入多少糖？节目的后半部分要靠数学了。我知道。然后，好吧，你们这群人，来拿块饼干。好吧。味道怎么样，伙计们？
We're getting some thumbs up. I'm getting mouths full with thumbs up. They're so soft and chewy. That's what she said. Oh, gosh. It's so early into the show. This is fantastic. Thank you.
我们得到了几个大拇指。我看到塞满食物的嘴和竖起的大拇指。它们太松软耐嚼了。这话她说的。哦，天哪。节目才刚开始没多久。这太棒了。谢谢。
We've got two. That's what she said. Oh, no. That is a strong homemade whiskey. This leads me perfectly into our first letter from our fan mail. This is from Jenny. She wrote in and said, hi, I'm from Indianapolis, Indiana. I'm a huge fan of the podcast and wanted to send you a small treat.
我们有两个。这话她说的。哦，不。那是高度的自制威士忌。这完美地引出了我们粉丝来信的第一封信。这是珍妮（Jenny）写的。她写道：“你好，我来自印第安纳州印第安纳波利斯。我是播客的超级粉丝，想送你们一点小零食。”
I'm a travel nurse, so I spend a lot of time away from my family and loved ones. And right now, I'm on assignment at St. Louis Children's Hospital. Hey, that's a great hospital. She said, shout out to Jenna's hometown. And while she was in St. Louis, she found a family-owned chocolate factory. I think I know who this is. Really? Yes.
“我是一名旅行护士，所以我花了很多时间远离家人和挚爱。目前，我正在圣路易斯儿童医院执行任务。”嘿，那是一家很棒的医院。她说，向詹娜的家乡致敬。当她在圣路易斯时，她发现了一家家族经营的巧克力工厂。我想我知道这是谁。真的吗？是的。
Jenna, she says they do free tours of their factory. Oh, my God. It is the chocolate, chocolate, chocolate company. And she sent us their truffles. Look how delicious these look. She said, I love you ladies, thanks for the podcast that I can take with me wherever I go. P.S. Toby is the Scranton Strangler. Thank you so much, Jenny.
詹娜，她说他们提供免费的工厂参观。天呐。这就是“巧克力，巧克力，巧克力”公司。她给我们寄了他们的松露巧克力。看看这些看起来多美味。她说：“我爱你们女士们，感谢这个无论我走到哪里都能随身携带的播客。”附言：托比就是斯克兰顿扼喉手。非常感谢你，珍妮。
These are delicious. Ooh, I want to eat one. And I want to go to the chocolate, chocolate, chocolate company. Yeah. Here are the flavors. Sea salt caramel. Mm-hmm. Fresh mint.
这些太美味了。哦，我想吃一个。我想去“巧克力，巧克力，巧克力”公司。是的。这些是口味。海盐焦糖。嗯哼。鲜薄荷。
Birthday cake. Fresh raspberry. Italian espresso. Red velvet cake. And white Euro dark. They look delicious. There you go, Jenna. I'm going to eat one.
生日蛋糕。新鲜树莓。意式浓缩咖啡。红丝绒蛋糕。还有白欧式黑巧克力。它们看起来太美味了。给你，詹娜。我要吃一个。
How is that? That's really good. Sitting to my right is a wrapped gift from Sam. Ah, yes. We have one small treat. This isn't your Christmas present. This is very specific in my free time when I'm not making your show. Do a fair amount of nerdy things in my free time.
味道怎么样？真的很好吃。坐在我右边的是萨姆包好的礼物。啊，是的。我们有一个小礼物。这不是你的圣诞礼物。这非常具体，在我的空闲时间里，当我不制作你们的节目时。我会在空闲时间做相当多书呆子的事情。
Mm-hmm. This is true. Was at a nerdy event recently. Was it a Comic-Con? It might have been. There was a gentleman at this thing that I paid to stand in his line. I explained to him that some of us very much enjoy and know all the lore and some of us do not.
嗯哼。确实如此。最近去了一个书呆子聚会。是漫展吗？可能是吧。那里有一位绅士，我付钱排队站在他队伍里。我向他解释说，我们有些人非常喜欢并了解所有的背景知识，而有些人则不然。
Oh, no. Is this a Lord of the Rings thing? You may open your gifts. All right. So it's signed by Mr. Frodo. What? Aw. I believe yours says to a true fan and yours says, why don't you like my movie?
哦，不。这是《指环王》的东西吗？你们可以打开礼物了。好吧。所以这是弗罗多先生签名的。什么？啊。我猜你的上面写着“致真正的粉丝”，而你的写着“你们为什么不喜欢我的电影？”
It does. Mine says, why don't you like my movie? Cassie, here's yours. Ainsley, sorry, yours is at home, but I do have one for you. Aw. Oh, my gosh. That is hilarious. He is familiar with the office.
确实如此。我的写着：“你们为什么不喜欢我的电影？”卡西，这是你的。安斯利，抱歉，你的在家里，但我确实为你准备了一份。啊。哦，天哪。太搞笑了。他对《办公室》很熟悉。
And when I explained who this is for, it laughed very, very hard. That is amazing. I don't know if you know this, but I was in Vancouver working on a show the same time that Elijah was working on a show. And we would all hang out. We actually watched a game of thrones all together at a pub. It was so much fun. And we got these beers that were like the size of our heads.
当我解释这是给谁的时，他笑得非常非常大声。这太棒了。我不知道你们知不知道，我当时在温哥华拍一部剧，正好赶上伊利亚也在拍剧。我们经常一起出去玩。我们其实还在一家酒吧里一起看了《权力的游戏》。太好玩了。我们还拿了那种有我们脑袋那么大的啤酒。
And we took pictures. The beers were so big. But he is one of the nicest people. He wants to do a birthday video for my son, Jack, who loved Lord of the Rings. He really was. He was one of those. He has that thing I like in an artist you admire. Where he had no questions.
我们拍了照片。啤酒太大了。但他真的是最随和的人之一。他想为我喜欢《指环王》的儿子杰克录制一段生日视频。他真的是。他是那种我在我所钦佩的艺术家身上喜欢的那种人。他没有任何问题。
I go, hey, it's for the people in the office. One of them explains this. One of them loves it and one of them doesn't, he goes, totally got it. Just immediately. Thank you, Sam. I will cherish this signed picture from a movie I've never seen. That breaks my spirit every time you say it. And that is not just because I'm friends with Elijah.
我说，嘿，这是给《办公室》的人准备的。其中一个人很了解这个，其中一个人喜欢，而另一个人不喜欢，他说，完全明白。立刻就懂了。谢谢你，萨姆。我会珍藏这张来自我从未看过的电影的签名照片的。每次你这么说，我都备受打击。这不仅仅是因为我和伊利亚是朋友。
Oh my God. I want him on the podcast. I want him if we ever break down Lord of the Rings. Oh, no. He could school you. You're saying we should break down Lord of the Rings so that you make me watch it. I know you. I know you.
哦，天哪。我想让他上播客。如果我们以后剖析《指环王》，我想让他来。哦，不。他可以狠狠教育你。你是说我们应该剖析《指环王》，好让你逼我看？我了解你。我了解你。
It's busted. All right. Well, listen, when I was going through our mail, I found a truly delightful gift that was sent in by one of our listeners. It's a book. Oh, and it came with this note. Dear office ladies, my name is Jasmine and I am from Roseville, California. I am a fan of the show, your podcast and your book.
露馅了。好吧，听着，当我整理我们的邮件时，我发现了一份由听众寄来的真正令人愉快的礼物。是一本书。哦，它还附带着这张便条。亲爱的办公室女士们，我叫茉莉（Jasmine），来自加利福尼亚州罗斯维尔。我是这部剧、你们的播客和你们的书的粉丝。
Jenna, I love your deep dives. I recently read this book and thought you would really love it as it is a whole book of deep dives written very comedically. And here it is, Angela. It's called Quackery, a brief history of the worst ways to cure everything. Like this is your Christmas present. This is your favorite thing. If I had known about this book, I would have asked for it for Christmas.
詹娜，我喜欢你的深度剖析。我最近读了这本书，觉得你们一定会非常喜欢它，因为它整本书都是以非常喜剧化的方式写的深度剖析。就是这本，安吉拉。书名叫《江湖郎术：治愈一切最糟糕方法的简史》。这就像是你的圣诞礼物。这是你最喜欢的东西。如果我早知道这本书，我就会把它当作圣诞礼物要来了。
But I don't need to because Jasmine sent it to me. Jasmine, you've made her day. Here's what else she said. I marked my favorite part about the origins of the phrase, blowing smoke up your ass. I hope you enjoy it. Oh my God, please tell me that's what that post-it's for. That's what the post-it's for, lady. So here it is, sit back, enjoy your beverages and your treats.
但我不需要，因为茉莉把它寄给了我。茉莉，你让她今天过得太开心了。她还写了下面这些。我标记了我最喜欢的部分，关于“往你屁股里吹烟”这个短语的起源。希望你们喜欢。哦，天哪，千万别告诉我这就是那个便签纸的用途。这就是便签纸的用途，女士。所以，靠回椅背，享受你们的饮料和零食吧。
And I'm going to tell you the origins of the phrase, blowing smoke up your ass. Jasmine, thank you in advance. In the 18th century, blowing smoke up someone's ass was a sanctioned resuscitation method for someone who had drowned. Stop it. Yes. So if I, like, fell into a lake, you... Someone would have to...
我要告诉你们“往你屁股里吹烟”这个短语的起源。茉莉，先谢谢你。在18世纪，往某人屁股里吹烟是对溺水者的一种官方认可的复苏方法。住手。是的。所以如果我，比如，掉进湖里，你……就会有人必须……
Yep. Oh, Lord. Yes. They made tobacco smoke enema kits, and everyone was encouraged to have one on hand, like a first aid kit. To blow tobacco? Mm-hmm. Schmini?
是的。哦，天哪。是的。他们制作了烟草烟雾灌肠套件，每个人都被鼓励随身准备一套，就像急救包一样。往里面吹烟草？嗯哼。像迷你烟斗？
Yep. You put the tube, and you put the tube in the person's butt, and then you used a fumigator to create the smoke, and then a bellows. You know, a bellows is that accordion thing that you use to blow air on a fire. Uh-huh. I'll show you a picture of it. Here it is. That looks horrifying.
是的。你把管子，把管子放进那个人的屁股里，然后你用一个熏烟器来产生烟草烟雾，再用一个风箱。你知道，风箱就是那种用来给火吹气的风琴状东西。嗯哼。我给你们看一张照片。就是这个。看起来太可怕了。
Oh my God, it's so much bigger than I thought. That's a lot of air up your butt. It is. So the original first aid kits did not have a bellows. Guess what? They're too big to fit in a first aid kit. Well, when you didn't have it, you had to blow the smoke into the tube yourself with your mouth.
哦，天哪，它比我想象的要大得多。那是很大一股气吹进屁股里啊。确实如此。所以最初的急救包并没有风箱。你猜怎么着？它们太大惹，塞不进急救包。好吧，当你没有风箱时，你必须用自己的嘴把烟吹进管子里。
But this was a problem because sometimes people would accidentally inhale. Oh God. And then they would get sick and sometimes die. Like if the person you had rescued from drowning had cholera, and then you inhale the air from their butt, you could die, apparently. It wasn't good. So you should be thankful that they added the bellows. I am speechless that this was like a common practice.
但这有个问题，因为有时人们会不小心吸入。哦，天哪。然后他们就会生病，有时甚至会死。就像如果你从溺水中救出的人有霍乱，然后你吸入了他们屁股里的空气，显然你可能会死。这可不太好。所以你们应该庆幸他们加上了风箱。我简直说不出话来，这竟然是一种常见做法。
It's like, he has fever. Get the leeches and blow up his ass. It was happening. According to the book, drowning happened so regularly in England along the River Thames that there was actually a special society formed and funded to promote the resuscitation of drowned people. Society. It was.
这就像是，他发烧了。拿来水蛭，往他屁股里吹气。这真的发生过。根据这本书的记载，泰晤士河沿岸的英国溺水事件非常普遍，以至于实际上成立并资助了一个专门的协会，来促进溺水者的复苏。协会。是的。
It was called, it's a very long name. This sounds like something Dwight made up. It was called the institution for affording immediate relief to persons apparently dead from drowning. That's their real name. Members of this group would walk along the banks of the river with their tobacco smoke enema kit in case they stumbled upon a person who needed help. I'll tell you, you're speechless right now.
它被称为，名字非常长。这听起来像是德 Dwight 编造的东西。它被称为“为明显溺水死亡人员提供即时救济的机构”。那是他们的真实名字。这个组织的成员会带着他们的烟草烟雾灌肠套件沿着河岸巡视，以防他们偶然发现需要帮助的人。我告诉你，你现在说不出话来了。
You're just shaking your. I am speechless. The idea behind this medical treatment was that it would do two things. Number one, it would warm up the drowned victim. Number two. It would make your butthole burn. Don't know. And maybe from the burning sensation you would awake.
你只是在摇着头。我简直说不出话来。这种医学疗法背后的想法是它可以起到两个作用。第一，它会使溺水受害者变暖。第二。会让你的肛门燃烧。不知道。也许你会从这种灼烧感中醒过来。
Number two, it would stimulate respiration. How? Exactly. It did neither. Which is where we get the phrase blowing smoke up your ass. Which means something that does nothing to help you. I will never ever say that lightly ever again. I want to say, incidentally, if the smoke enema didn't work, the second method of helping
第二，它会刺激呼吸。怎么做？准确地说。它两者都没做到。这就是我们得到“往你屁股里吹烟”这个短语的由来。意思是对你毫无帮助的事情。我再也不会轻描淡写地使用这个词了。顺便说一下，如果烟雾灌肠不管用，帮助溺水者的第二种方法
a drowning person was to give them mouth to mouth resuscitation, but that was considered a vulgar last resort. Like you only, I mean, disgusting. Yeah. To put your mouth on someone else's mouth. My God. It's horrifying. Much better to remove their pants.
是进行人工呼吸，但这被认为是一种粗俗的最后手段。就像你只有，我的意思是，太恶心了。是的。把你的嘴贴在别人的嘴上。天哪。太可怕了。最好还是脱掉他们的裤子。
And stick a tube up their butt and blow in it. That's right. Woo. So there you go. Where do we go from this? I don't know, but Jasmine, you made my year. There are so many good things in this and I will be bringing it out often in 2023. Seriously, Jasmine.
把管子插进他们的屁股里然后往里面吹。没错。呜。所以就是这样。我们从这能聊到哪去？我不知道，但茉莉，你成就了我的一年。这里面有太多好东西了，我将在2023年经常把它拿出来说。说真的，茉莉。
Wow. Well, you know, Jenna, a lot of folks also wrote in and told us where they like to listen to the podcast and how, sometimes why, right? Yes. I loved this letter from Casey and Casey, I couldn't find the envelope. So I'm not quite sure where in the country you are, but Casey wrote us this. I tune in every Saturday morning as I clean the house. You ladies help me make it fun and get me through.
哇。好吧，你知道吗，詹娜，许多人还写信告诉我们他们喜欢在哪里听播客以及如何听，有时是为什么，对吧？是的。我很喜欢凯西（Casey）的这封信，凯西，我找不到信封了。所以我不太确定你在国家的哪个地方，但凯西给我们写了这些。我每星期六早晨一边打扫房间一边收听。你们女士们帮我把它变得有趣并陪我度过难关。
But most recently, I tuned into your 100th episode to help calm my nerves and get me through a root canal. A root canal. Yes. The staff at the endodontist office thought it was a very funny but smart choice when I brought in my earbuds and asked if I could listen to my podcast. She had a root canal without being put all the way down, all the way under. No one's put all the way under.
但最近，我收听了你们的第100期节目，来帮我平复紧张情绪并度过根管治疗。根管治疗。是的。牙髓病医师诊所的工作人员认为，当我拿出耳机并询问是否可以听我的播客时，这是一个非常有趣但明智的选择。她做根管治疗时没有被完全麻醉，没有被完全放倒。没人被完全放倒。
I was. I was. I was not. Oh. Yeah. Oh no. I was there. I was present.
我被放倒了。我被放倒了。我没有。哦。是啊。哦，不。我在那儿。我是清醒的。
Wow. Yeah. She writes on to say, thank you both so much for being so genuine and open with your listening audience. Jenna, you remind me of my type A self and Angela, you make my day because your responses to her. What? Because your responses to and love for her reminds me of my BFF.
哇。是的。她接着写道：“非常感谢你们俩对听众如此真诚和开放。詹娜，你让我想起了我这种A型人格的人，而安吉拉，你让我的一天都很开心，因为你对她的回应。什么？因为你对她的回应和对她的爱让我想起了我的好闺蜜。”
Aw. Thanks for helping me overcome my nerves and get through a procedure that I was not looking forward to. And then she sent pictures of her three kids and their dog who they named Bratton after Creed Bratton. Oh. I love that. I love that.
啊。谢谢你们帮我克服紧张，度过了一个我并不期待的医疗过程。然后她发来了她三个孩子和他们的狗的照片，他们给狗起名叫布拉顿（Bratton），随克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）。哦。我喜欢这样。我喜欢这样。
Thank you. Well, one of my favorite things to open when we get our mail are letters that come from kids and teenagers who love office ladies. And I wanted to share a few of their letters. So the first one is from Ellie who is 11 years old who said, I have been watching the office since I was six. I am such a huge fan and I could swear I've memorized every piece of office trivia. I'm even watching Golden Ticket as I write this.
谢谢。好吧，当我们收到邮件时，我最喜欢打开的东西之一就是来自喜欢“办公室女士”的孩子和青少年的信。我想分享他们的一些信。所以第一封来自11岁的埃莉（Ellie），她说：“我从六岁起就开始看《办公室》了。我是如此狂热的粉丝，我敢发誓我已经背下了每一个办公室冷知识。我甚至在写这封信时都在看《金奖券》。”
I love Angela as I share the same love of cats. I don't lick them though. And I adore Pam in her perseverance and resilience. I'm really proud of those two vocabulary words. I know for 11 years old. Ellie says, I listen to your podcast every day, even multiple times a week. I would love for you guys to read this letter on air. But if you can't, it's okay.
“我喜欢安吉拉，因为我们对猫有着同样的爱。不过我可不舔它们。而且我很崇拜潘的坚忍不拔和韧性。”我真的很为这两个词汇感到骄傲。我知道，对于11岁来说。埃莉说：“我每天都听你们的播客，甚至一周听好几遍。我很希望你们能在节目中读这封信。但如果你们不能，也没关系。”
Just knowing that you read this makes me smile. Awe. Ellie, your letter made me smile. Yes. And also your comedic tag at the end, PS, I hope this letter has an oaky after birth. Oh my goodness. Oh my goodness. We also got a very sweet letter from Lily who wrote to us on some beat stationery.
“只要知道你们读了这个就能让我微笑。”啊。埃莉，你的信让我露出了微笑。是的。还有你在最后的搞笑附言，附言：我希望这封信有种橡木余味。哦天哪。哦天哪。我们还收到了一封来自莉莉（Lily）的非常甜美的信，她写在一张拍纸簿上。
She stamped her letter girls rule. She said, I would like to start by saying I love your podcast. I enjoy all your tangents, stories and insights into your life on the office. I am 12 years old. I'm from Newbury Park, California. And she watches the show with her sister and now she's been listening to the podcast. She listens on road trips, plane rides. While she's doing her homework, and at times when she's sad or stressed out, she's listened
她在信上盖了“女孩统治”的印章。她说：“我想先说我非常喜欢你们的播客。我喜欢你们所有的题外话、故事以及对你们在《办公室》生活的见解。我今年12岁。我来自加利福尼亚州纽伯里帕克。”她和姐姐一起看这部剧，现在她一直在听播客。她在公路旅行、飞机上听。
to every episode about a hundred times and she crushes all her family members in office trivia now. And next up is Valena or Valena. I hope I'm pronouncing your name correctly. Who wrote to say, I am a big fan of the show and the podcast. In my class, we had to write a thank you letter to someone and I picked you. My mom and I love your podcast. I made a collage of the office.
当她做家庭作业时，以及在悲伤或压力大的时候，她已经把每一集听了一百遍了，现在她在办公室冷知识方面秒杀所有的家庭成员。接下来是瓦莱娜（Valena）。希望我没有读错你的名字。她写道：“我是这部剧和播客的超级粉丝。在我的课堂上，我们必须给某人写一封感谢信，我选择了你们。我和妈妈都喜欢你们播客。我制作了一幅《办公室》的拼贴画。”
I was Dwight Schrute for Halloween. It was a fun costume that cost under $29. I love that. And I have three Funkos of the office. I love those letters. I also love it when parents write in and share with us that their children use the office and our podcast as part of their homework assignment. Oh, wow.
“我万圣节扮成了德 Dwight Schrute。那是一个有趣的服装，花费不到29美元。”我太喜欢了。我有三个《办公室》的Funko手办。我喜欢这些信。我也喜欢父母写信与我们分享他们的孩子将《办公室》和我们的播客作为他们家庭作业的一部分。哦，哇。
Yeah. Okay. So Annie wrote in and said her daughter, Iolana, wrote her persuasive paper on why the office is the best show ever and she used Office Ladies as part of the reason why and she got a four out of four grade, a perfect score. Very good. I know. Iolana is eight years old and I want to read you the last summation paragraph of her persuasive
是的。好吧。安妮（Annie）写信说她的女儿伊奥拉娜（Iolana）写了一篇关于为什么《办公室》是有史以来最好的节目的说服性论文，她将“办公室女士”作为原因的一部分，并且她得到了满分四分的好成绩，完美的满分。太棒了。我知道。伊奥拉娜八岁了，我想给你们读一下她的说服性论文的最后总结段落。
paper. All right. Quote. The last reason the office is the best show ever is there is a podcast called Office Ladies where Angela Kinsey and Jenna Fisher tell some fast facts and give interviews to people that were on the office. The Office Ladies also tell secrets about the office. Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey are also very funny and that makes the Office Ladies very
“引文。最后，《办公室》是有史以来最好的节目的原因是有一个叫做‘办公室女士’的播客，安吉拉·金西和詹娜·费舍尔在其中讲述一些快速的事实，并对曾出演过《办公室》的人进行采访。‘办公室女士’还讲述了关于《办公室》的秘密。詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西也非常搞笑，这使得‘办公室女士’非常讨人喜欢。”
likeable. In conclusion, the office is the best show ever. Four out of four. Yes. I agree. I got another letter from Jackson in Kansas City, Missouri. He's a seventh grader and as part of his ELA and reading class assignment, they had to write a fan letter and he chose the Office Ladies.
“总之，《办公室》是有史以来最好的节目。四分满分。”是的。我同意。我还收到了来自密苏里州堪萨斯城的杰克逊（Jackson）的一封信。他是一名七年级学生，作为他的ELA（英语语言艺术）和阅读课作业的一部分，他们必须写一封粉丝信，他选择了“办公室女士”。
Wow. Okay. Jackson said, quote, I love the Office Ladies podcast because it really breaks scenes down and gives us great details. Keep up the good work. Thank you, Jackson. And then Jenna and Jackson said he had two questions for us. Okay.
哇。好吧。杰克逊说：“引文：我喜欢‘办公室女士’播客，因为它真正剖析了场景并给我们提供了很棒的细节。继续保持出色的工作。谢谢你，杰克逊。”然后詹娜和杰克逊说他有两个问题要问我们。好吧。
Question one. On a scale of one to 10, how hard was it to keep it together when somebody messed up in the scene? Oh, for me, a 10. Yes. Like impossible. You know, if someone else is laughing, it's hard not to laugh with them and they're probably laughing because someone did something funny and I was already trying not to laugh.
问题一。在一到十的范围内，当有人在场景中搞砸时，保持不笑有多难？哦，对我来说，是10。是的。就像是不可能的。你知道，如果别人在笑，你很难不跟着笑，而且他们可能在笑是因为某人做了什么搞笑的事，而我已经在极力克制自己不笑了。
Right. I will say I was always relieved when someone else broke first. Yes. Because then you could kind of tuck into their laughter. Yes. Jackson, second question is, what is the hardest challenge as an actor? It's a big question. Jackson, I think it is the constant rejection.
对。我要说的是，每当别人先笑场时，我总是如释重负。是的。因为那样你就可以顺势融入他们的笑声中。是的。杰克逊的第二个问题是，作为演员最大的挑战是什么？这是一个很大的问题。杰克逊，我认为这是不断的拒绝。
You go on about a hundred job interviews or auditions for every one thing you get. So 99% of the time someone is saying, no, it's not you. And it's really hard to convince yourself to keep going. Yeah. And I would also say once you get an audition, just believing that you have something unique to bring to the part. When I was looking up Maggie Barrett and Will Ferrell's sketch at the Groundlings, I also found Will Ferrell's audition for Saturday Night Live.
你每得到一个工作机会，就要经历大约一百次面试或试镜。所以在99%的情况下，别人都在说，不，不是你。说服自己坚持下去真的很难。是的。而且我还要说，一旦你得到了试镜机会，只要相信你为这个角色带来了某种独特的东西。当我查阅玛吉·拜尔德和威尔·法瑞尔在格劳宁斯剧院的小品时，我还找到了威尔·法瑞尔为《周六夜现场》的试镜。
His original audition and I watched it and he is doing these hilarious characters to silence. Wow. And just the mental fortitude to just be like, okay, I believe that this is funny. I believe in myself. I'm just going to keep doing it even though no one is responding. So there's some of that mental fitness that you just have to keep believing in yourself. Very well said, lady.
他最初的试镜，我看了，他在一片安静中表演这些搞笑的角色。哇。那种精神上的坚韧，就是去想，好吧，我相信这很有趣。我相信自己。我只是要继续做下去，即使没有人做出反应。所以有一种精神上的坚韧，你必须不断相信自己。说得太好了，女士。
Thank you. Well, Angela, we also got a gift from Ryan, who is 11 years old in Maryland. When we were breaking down costume contest, Michael has a line where he says, Halloween should be a day in which we celebrate monsters and not be mad at each other. And we said that would make a great mug. Yeah. Ryan made a mug of that and sent it to us. It's on my desk.
谢谢。好吧，安吉拉，我们还收到了来自马里兰州11岁男孩瑞安（Ryan）的礼物。当我们剖析服装大赛时，迈克尔有一句台词说：“万圣节应该是一个我们庆祝怪物而不是互相生气的日子。”我们说过那会是一个很棒的马克杯。是的。瑞安做了一个那样的马克杯并寄给了我们。它就在我的桌子上。
Thank you so much. We really loved it. We'll put a picture of it in office ladies pod. And then finally, Angela, we got a letter from Reese Castro, who said, I am 17 years old and I have cerebral palsy. Your podcast has inspired me to be the best version of myself. My favorite part of the podcast is the deep dives. You know what?
非常感谢。我们真的很喜欢。我们会把它的照片发在office ladies pod上。最后，安吉拉，我们收到了一封来自里斯·卡斯特罗（Reese Castro）的信，她说：“我今年17岁，患有脑瘫。你们的播客激发我成为最好的自己。播客我最喜欢的部分是深度剖析。”你知道吗？
We really enjoy doing those. We do. Reese has an idea for an office spin-off show where the show is about what happens with Jim and Pam and Daryl over at Athlete, but the big plot twist is that Dwight joins the athlete team. They hire Dwight? Is Jim one of the hires? Is Jim one of the hires?
我们真的很喜欢做这些。我们确实很喜欢。里斯对《办公室》衍生剧有一个想法，剧的内容是关于吉姆、潘和达里尔在阿特莱特（Athlete）发生的事情，但最大的剧情反转是德 Dwight 加入了阿特莱特团队。他们雇佣了德 Dwight？吉姆是受雇者之一吗？吉姆是受雇者之一吗？
Dwight. And you know that means Angela is coming along. Well, you betcha. Reese, absolutely, if there was going to be an office reunion, we could not let Jim and Dwight not work together anymore. It's the ultimate, like, pranky, fun, foil couple. I even think that they would grow old pranking each other. Yes, I believe they would.
德 Dwight。你知道这意味着安吉拉也会一起去。好吧，当然。里斯，绝对的，如果会有《办公室》重聚，我们不能让吉姆和德 Dwight 不再一起工作。这是终极的、恶作剧的、有趣的、势均力敌的一对。我甚至认为他们会一起恶作剧变老。是的，我相信他们会。
It would be like two old men giggling at their pranks. Angela, should we get to your favorite part of our mail? This lights up, Angela's soul. We got a lot of wedding invites. You know I love them all. I want to list every single person that sent one in, but then this whole episode would basically be wedding invitations because we got probably 600. I'm not exaggerating.
这就像两个老头在恶作剧时咯咯傻笑。安吉拉，我们要不要来看看你最喜欢的邮件部分？这个会发光，是安吉拉的灵魂。我们收到了很多婚礼请柬。你知道我都爱。我想把每一个寄信人的名字都列出来，但那样的话，这一整集基本上就全成了婚礼请柬，因为我们大概收到了600封。我没夸张。
Angela, in our old age, I want us to start accepting these wedding invites. We could eat free every weekend of the year by just going around to weddings. We would be traveling a lot. But you guys, I do want to single out a few people. Here are just a few, Taylor and Brady of Iva, South Carolina, who currently live long distance and listen to office ladies when they traveled to see each other, Alec and McKenna of Washington, who first bonded over the office, Jenny and Johnny of Noon in Georgia, who sent us a wedding invite with a note.
安吉拉，等我们老了，我想让我们开始接受这些婚礼请柬。我们只要到处去参加婚礼，一年里的每个周末都能白吃白喝。我们要到处旅行了。不过大家，我确实想特别提几个人。这只是其中几位，来自南卡罗来纳州艾瓦的泰勒和布雷迪，他们目前处于异地恋，在去看望彼此的途中收听“办公室女士”；来自华盛顿的亚历克和麦肯娜，他们因为《办公室》最初结缘；来自佐治亚州诺恩的珍妮和强尼，他们寄给我们的婚礼请柬里附了一张便条。
She said that Johnny introduced her to the office and it's one of the cornerstones of their relationship. And our podcast is the only podcast they listen to together for 16 hours non-stop when they drove from Georgia to New York to visit family. Oh, I'm sorry. That's so much of us. Is that too much of us? 16 hours.
她说强尼带她认识了《办公室》，这是他们感情的基石之一。我们的播客是他们一起收听的唯一播客，当他们从佐治亚州开车到纽约探亲时，连续16个小时都在听。哦，我很抱歉。我们占的篇幅是不是太多了？我们占的篇幅是不是太多了？16个小时。
16 hours. We love you. One more. Jenny and Ryan of Orlando, Florida, Jenny added a note with their wedding invitation that stated this, Hi Angela, I hope you used your new mail opener for this letter. I did. And then she went on to say, my fiance and I love to listen to you every week. We own the DVD set and we are rewatching with you.
16个小时。我们爱你们。还有一个。来自佛罗里达州奥兰多的珍妮和瑞恩，珍妮在他们的婚礼请柬附言中写道：嗨，安吉拉，希望你用新拆信刀打开了这封信。我用了。然后她接着说，我和未婚夫每周都喜欢听你们的节目。我们拥有DVD套装，而且我们在和你们一起重温。
I have two more folks to shout out. Hi. I'm calling this good use of a wax seal. Oh, you do love a wax seal. I do. I do. Shout out to Austin and Kirsten of Lafayette, Louisiana and another Austin and Nadia of Fairdale, Kentucky.
我还有两位朋友要感谢。嗨。我觉得这个蜡封用得太妙了。哦，你确实很喜欢蜡封。我是。我是。向路易斯安那州拉斐特的奥斯汀和克斯顿，以及肯塔基州费尔代尔的另一位奥斯汀和娜迪亚致意。
Excellent use of wax seal. Very nice. Very nice. Angela, in my pile of physical mail, I also got a wedding invite from Abby and Jonathan who are getting married in April of next year. According to what Abby wrote, I wish that I could describe to you how much your podcast means to me. I had been listening to it from the beginning and was listening when I was proposed to.
蜡封用得极好。非常好，非常好。安吉拉，在我的实体信件堆里，我也收到了一份来自艾比和乔纳森的婚礼请柬，他们将在明年四月结婚。根据艾比所写的，我真希望我能向你们描述你们的播客对我的意义有多重大。我从一开始就在听，被求婚的时候也正在听。
What? Yes. It felt only fitting to include you in our special day with an invite to our wedding. We even have a Nard Dog quote in our ceremony. I feel honored. I want to know the Nard Dog quote in your ceremony. In addition to all these wonderful wedding invites, we receive holiday cards, graduation announcements, birthday wishes, so many wonderful cards, even handmade cards.
什么？是的。能把你们的名字写进我们的特殊日子里，邀请你们参加我们的婚礼，我觉得再合适不过了。我们的婚礼仪式上甚至还有一句“纳德狗”的名言。我感到很荣幸。我想知道你们仪式上的“纳德狗”名言是什么。除了所有这些精彩的婚礼请柬，我们还收到节日贺卡、毕业公告、生日祝福、那么多精彩的卡片，甚至是手工卡片。
Baby shower invites. Oh, I have a baby shower invite. Oh. Yeah, I brought one. Okay. This is Robin of Brownsburg, Indiana. She included a note with the baby shower invite because, Jenna, she was going to throw her best friend, Missy, a small baby shower and call it a baby sprinkle.
迎婴派对请柬。哦，我有一份迎婴派对请柬。哦。对，我带来了一份。好的。这是印第安纳州布朗斯堡的罗宾。她在迎婴派对请柬里附了一张便条，因为，珍娜，她打算为她的好闺蜜米茜办一个小型迎婴派对，称之为“婴儿洒水派对（baby sprinkle）”。
Oh. Yeah, a small shower is a sprinkle, and as it turns out, during this time, Robin and her husband were redoing their floors and going through all their old cabinets, and they found Robin's great grandmother's tea set and teapot. So Robin said, I decided to throw my friend a finer things club baby sprinkle, or as Angela would say, a finer things club sprinkle. I love this so much. She went on to say, they're huge fans of the show and the podcast, and that she is
哦。对，小型派对就是“洒水派对”，结果证明，就在这段时间里，罗宾和她丈夫在重新整修地板，清理所有旧橱柜时，他们找到了罗宾曾祖母的茶具和茶壶。所以罗宾说，我决定为我的朋友办一场“精致生活俱乐部婴儿洒水派对”，或者用安吉拉的话说，一场“精致生活俱乐部洒水派对”。我太喜欢这个了。她接着说，他们是这部剧和播客的超级粉丝，而且她
sad that we're getting close to the end of the rewatch, but she is super excited to hear or see whatever we do next. That is so sweet. Just the sweetest thing. We also get letters that we keep a lot of expecting moms and new parents company. Like this letter from Bethany and Pasadena, Texas, about her son, Joseph. Bethany wrote this. During Joseph's almost six-week NICU Stay, You Ladies Kept Me Company, Bethany went on
很难过我们快要看完剧了，但她对我们接下来要做的任何事情都超级兴奋。太甜了。简直不能再甜了。我们还收到信件，说我们陪伴了许多准妈妈和新手父母。就像这封来自得克萨斯州帕萨迪纳的贝瑟尼写给我们的信，关于她的儿子约瑟夫。贝瑟尼是这样写的。在约瑟夫将近六周的NICU住院期间，是你们陪伴了我。贝瑟尼接着
to say that she would normally listen to the podcast on her drives to and from work, but before her son was born, she was put on bed rest so the episodes piled up. As a result, she had a bunch to listen to on her drives to and from the hospital each day for weeks. She said, quote, You ladies kept my mind occupied when my heart ached, and you cheered me up and made me laugh when I cried after going home with empty arms. I am so grateful to you and your team for that. I'll end with a high note.
说她通常在上下班开车时听播客，但在她儿子出生前，她被要求卧床保胎，所以积攒了很多集没听。因此，连续几个星期，她每天开车上下班去医院时，有一堆节目可以听。她说，引述：“当我心痛时，你们让我的大脑有了寄托；当我空着双手回家哭泣时，你们让我振作起来，逗我笑。我和我的团队非常感激你们和你们的团队。”我以一个积极的音符结束。
Joey turned eight months old yesterday and is thriving. He is meeting all of his milestones and is one of the happiest little babies you'll ever meet. And most importantly, he's a healthy and loved little boy. Mm. That's so sweet. Mm-hmm. She included a little picture.
乔伊昨天满八个月了，而且发育得很好。他达到了所有的成长里程碑，是你见过的最快乐的小宝宝之一。最重要的是，他是一个健康且被深爱着的小男孩。嗯。太甜了。嗯哼。她附了一张小照片。
Look at that sweet face. Oh, that's a cute baby. I know. Well, Bethany, I'm so glad we could keep you company during that time. Me too. So Angela, I know that people often include the office in their celebrations. Mm-hmm. And we got a really touching letter from Ashley R. in Columbus, Ohio.
看那张甜美的脸。哦，真是个可爱的宝宝。我知道。好吧，贝瑟尼，我很高兴能在那个时期陪伴你。我也是。所以安吉拉，我知道大家经常把《办公室》融入他们的庆祝活动中。嗯哼。我们收到了来自俄亥俄州哥伦布市的阿什利·R的一封非常感人的信。
It included two photos that look like a pregnancy announcement. In one of them, her and her husband are kissing and they're holding a sign that says, Dwight, and in the subs, along with a photo of their ultrasound. So cute. And the other photo is of a little boy who's in an assistant to the regional manager shirt next to a sign that says, Baby R. due January, 2021. And there's a little banner that says, It is a baby. So I thought that was so sweet.
里面包含了两张看起来像怀孕公告的照片。其中一张里，她和丈夫正在接吻，手里举着一块写着“德怀特”的牌子，照片旁边还有他们的B超照片。太可爱了。另一张照片是一个小男孩，穿着一件“地区经理助理”字样的衬衫，旁边是一块写着“R宝宝，预产期2021年1月”的牌子。还有一个小横幅上面写着：“是个宝宝。”所以我认为这太甜了。
So cute. Then I read her letter. And here's what she said, I wanted to take a moment to share my story and explain the photos with this letter. In February, 2020, my husband and I decided to try for our second child. Our first was a huge surprise to us just after we got engaged, just like Jim and Pam. So her and her husband had a son, that's the little boy who was in the picture. She went on to say, The idea of trying for a baby was new to us.
太可爱了。然后我读了她的信。她是这么说的，我希望能花点时间分享我的故事，并在这封信里解释这些照片。2020年2月，我和丈夫决定尝试要我们的第二个孩子。我们的第一个孩子在我们订婚后是个巨大的惊喜，就像吉姆和帕姆一样。所以她和丈夫有一个儿子，就是照片里那个小男孩。她接着说，尝试要个宝宝对我们来说是个新概念。
But we got pregnant on the first try. We saw baby O. Baby O is what they were calling the baby because they didn't know yet if it was a boy or a girl. They saw baby O in an ultrasound at eight weeks and two days. And since we didn't get to celebrate and have an announcement with our first, we were excited to make an announcement this time around. And we decided on an office theme. As you can see in the pictures, my husband and I got picnic shirts made.
但我们一击即中。我们在怀孕八周零两天时的B超中看到了“O宝宝”。O宝宝是他们对这个孩子的称呼，因为他们还不知道是男孩还是女孩。我们在八周零两天时的B超中看到了O宝宝，既然我们的第一个孩子没能好好庆祝和发布公告，我们这次很高兴能发布一个公告。我们决定采用《办公室》主题。正如你在照片里看到的，我和丈夫定制了野餐衬衫。
So cute. They did. So they really went with the company picnic theme. She said they posted the pictures to announce and celebrate. And then she goes on to explain that just a couple weeks later, they lost the baby. And that these pictures that she sent are the only prints that she has of this memory. And she would love it if we would post the photos in Office Ladies Pod when we post things from fans because that way, the pictures will be a part of a place that celebrates their
太可爱了。他们真的定制了。所以他们真的采用了公司野餐的主题。她说他们发布了这些照片来宣布和庆祝。然后她接着解释说，仅仅几周后，他们就失去了这个宝宝。她寄来的这些照片是她关于这段记忆仅有的冲洗照片。如果能在《办公室女士》播客发布粉丝的东西时把这些照片发出来，她会非常高兴，因为这样一来，这些照片就会成为一个庆祝他们
favorite show rather than locked away in some box somewhere. Ashley, we will definitely post the photos. And I want you to know, Ashley also says that she has since welcomed twins Oliver and Olivia, who joined their big brother, Milo. Oh my goodness. Oh, Ashley, thank you so much for sharing that with us. I know. That is so touching.
最喜欢的节目地方的一部分，而不是被锁在某处的某个盒子里。阿什利，我们一定会发布这些照片的。我想让你知道，阿什利还说，她后来迎来了双胞胎奥利弗和奥利维亚，他们加入了大哥哥米洛的行列。噢天哪。哦，阿什利，非常感谢你与我们分享这些。我知道。太感人了。
Yeah. And we will definitely post the photos. Yeah. Well, we love being able to support new parents in any way we can. And you know, Jen and I love being moms. It is the hardest job, but it's the best job. Yep. But there's so much you have to carry around as a parent.
是的。我们一定会发布这些照片的。嗯。好吧，我们喜欢以任何可能的方式支持新手父母。你知道，珍娜和我喜欢当妈妈。这是最难的工作，但也是最好的工作。没错。但作为父母，你要操心的事情太多了。
I worry even in the best of times. I know. And it's nice to know you're not alone in that. That's right. We also heard from a few of you who love our tangents that we go on. In particular, Jenna, when you get on your soapbox. Oh, thank you. Are you ready for this one?
即使在最好的时期我也会担心。我知道。知道自已在这点上并不孤单，这种感觉真好。没错。我们还听到一些非常喜欢我们跑题的听众的反馈。特别是珍娜，当你开始夸夸其谈的时候。哦，谢谢。准备好听这个了吗？
Hi, Jenna and Angela. I've been listening to your podcast since 2020 and it's really been such a great companion. It's like we are hanging out with our BFFs. I think that what I love most about your show is you celebrate, respect and empower each other and other women. In parentheses, she says, stay on your soapbox, Jenna. I really appreciate this because I do sometimes get some haters. Some snarkies.
嗨，珍娜和安吉拉。我从2020年开始听你们的播客，它真的是一个伟大的陪伴。就像我们在和最好的闺蜜一起闲逛。我认为我最喜欢你们节目的一点是，你们互相庆祝、尊重和赋能，也这样对待其他女性。括号里，她说，坚持你的长篇大论，珍娜。我真的很感激这一点，因为我有时确实会遇到一些恶评者。一些刻薄鬼。
For my soapboxes. So thank you for the love. She goes on to say, I am grateful that the two of you promote sisterhood. I'm also inspired by your creative success. Keep rocking it. I'm including an official invitation for you guys to be lifetime members of the FCW Society. What is the FCW Society? It stands for F***ing Cool Women Friends.
针对我的夸夸其谈。所以谢谢你们的爱。她接着说，我很感激你们两个宣扬姐妹情谊。我也被你们的创意成功所启发。继续保持。我随信附上一份官方邀请函，邀请你们成为FCW协会的终身会员。什么是FCW协会？它代表“他妈的酷女性朋友（F***ing Cool Women Friends）”。
I love it. And she gave us like a little card. Oh, it's a membership card. Yeah. Here's what it says. We're lifetime members and the card says, FCW Society is dedicated to promoting and exploring feminist issues and interests while spreading the word and celebrating the fact that women are so f***ing cool.
我太喜欢了。她还给了我们一张小卡片。哦，这是一张会员卡。是的。上面是这样写的。我们是终身会员，卡上写着：FCW协会致力于推广和探索女性议题与兴趣，同时传播和庆祝女性是如此他妈的酷这一事实。
I'm putting it in my wallet. I love it. Oh, there is a Facebook page for this society. I know. Thank you, Joanne and Georgia. That really lifted me up. I have another one. Oh.
我要把它放进钱包里。我太喜欢了。哦，这个协会还有一个Facebook主页。我知道。谢谢你，佐治亚州的乔安妮。这真的让我振奋。我还有另一个。哦。
This is from Kayla and Dixon, Tennessee, who was very inspired by your rant about panty lines. Okay. She even made stickers of big panties with captions on them. They are hilarious. I will definitely be putting them in stories. Here's one. They're effing comfortable.
这是来自田纳西州迪克森的凯拉，她被你们关于内裤勒痕的吐槽深深启发了。好吧。她甚至制作了大内裤贴纸，上面配有文字。它们太滑稽了。我一定会把它们发到快拍里。这是其中一个。它们他妈的太舒服了。
Getting f***ed done. Feminists for pockets and panty lines. You should keep that one, Jenna. Oh my goodness. Can I please? I don't know where I'm putting it, but I want this sticker of giant underwear that says getting f***ed done. Okay.
把逼事搞定。争取口袋和内裤勒痕的女权主义者。你该留着那个，珍娜。噢天哪。我能留吗？我不知道该把它贴在哪儿，但我想要这个写着“把逼事搞定”的巨型内裤贴纸。好吧。
Here is the letter from Kayla that went along with the stickers. Dear Office Ladies, I look forward to new episodes of Office Ladies. Every single week, I love your tangents most of all. I love it when Jenna talks about feminism. I get self-conscious of panty lines sometimes, but your discussion on it really helped me. I mean, why would I? I have to wear panties. Chill.
这是凯拉随贴纸附上的信。亲爱的《办公室女士》，我期盼着《办公室女士》的新剧集。每周每周，我最喜欢的都是你们的跑题。我喜欢珍娜谈论女权主义的时候。有时我对内裤勒痕感到不自在，但你们的讨论真的帮到了我。我是说，我为什么要在意？我得穿内裤。冷静点。
I don't care if you see lines. Yes. Yes. These are all full of exclamation points, by the way. And then she goes on to write, I just got sticker paper and I made stickers inspired by your talk. Thank you so much for your podcast. It made me laugh all through my final year of college.
我不在乎你们看到勒痕。对。对。顺便说一句，这些都充满了感叹号。然后她接着写道，我刚买了一张贴纸纸，根据你们的谈话制作了贴纸。非常感谢你们的播客。它让我在大学最后一年里一直笑个不停。
Enjoy, Kayla. Kayla, I love it. I love it. And look at the creativity that it inspired. These are wonderful. While I am loving all these Boss Lady letters, I also found a Boss Lady letter from Nicole H. in Kansas City, Missouri, who said, I am from a smallish town outside of Kansas City. I really love listening to your friendship, your deep dives, and learning about my favorite
享受吧，凯拉。凯拉，我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。看看它激起的创意。这些太棒了。虽然我很喜欢所有这些“老板女士”的信件，但我也在密苏里州堪萨斯城的妮可·H那里发现了一封“老板女士”的信，她说，我来自堪萨斯城外围的一个小镇。我真的很喜欢听你们的友谊、深度剖析，并了解我最喜欢的
show. I also think all women's pants should have pockets. Agree. Nicole goes on to say, I went back to work in August teaching middle school reading. While I love teaching, it breaks my heart running around in the morning and dropping my kids off at daycare. So I decided to start my own business as a virtual assistant so I can work from home. So smart.
节目。我也认为所有女裤都应该有口袋。赞同。妮可接着说，我在八月重返工作岗位，教初中阅读。虽然我热爱教学，但早上到处奔忙并把孩子送到日托所让我心碎。所以我决定开创自己的虚拟助理业务，这样我就可以在家工作了。太聪明了。
I toyed with the idea for a while, but then I listened to one of your episodes when you described how you were really driven to start this podcast because you wanted flexible hours into be your own boss. Yeah. I thought, same lady. Did she write same lady? Yes. So cute.
我琢磨这个想法有一段时间了，然后我听了你们的一集播客，里面描述了你们创办这个播客的真正动力，因为你们想要灵活的工作时间并做自己的老板。对。我想，同道中人。她写的是“同道中人”吗？是的。太可爱了。
You were really encouraging. So I was like, okay, they did it. I can too. And while building my own business, I had to set my own prices and I remembered the information Jenna presented about how we tend to first negotiate with ourselves. I want to really thank you for that information because it's true. I went back and I reset my rates. I loved it when you talked about that.
你们真的很鼓励人。所以我想，好吧，她们做到了，我也能。在建立自己的业务时，我不得不自己定价，我记起了珍娜之前提出的观点，即我们倾向于首先与自己谈判。我真的要感谢你们提供的信息，因为这是真的。我回过头重新设定了我的费率。我太喜欢你们谈论这个了。
Yeah. And since you and I started this company together, how I approach my worth in our industry has completely changed. We talk about it all the time. When people reach out to us and they want to hire us for a gig, we so often apologize for being paid to do our work. I know. But not anymore.
是的。自从你和我一起创办这家公司以来，我对我们在行业中自身价值的看法发生了彻底的改变。我们一直在谈论这个。当人们联系我们并想雇我们干活时，我们经常为因完成工作而获得报酬而道歉。我知道。但现在不了。
Not anymore. Well, I think we should take a break. When we come back, I do have more deep dives, I'm not going to lie. If you like that portion of our show, this is the episode for you. We're also going to go back in time a little to some episodes that you guys wrote in about. We are back and we got some mail about past episodes. We really want to share with you. I'm so excited about these.
不再这样了。好吧，我想我们该休息一下了。当我们回来时，我确实还有更多的深度剖析，我不会撒谎的。如果你喜欢我们节目的那部分，这就是为你准备的一集。我们还将时光倒流一点，回到你们写信讨论过的一些剧集。我们回来了，我们收到了一些关于过去剧集的信件。我们真的很想与你们分享。我对此感到非常兴奋。
Me too. I got to kick it off with Olivia from Malvern, Pennsylvania. She said, I was just listening to your recent episode of the seminar and the post-stabilities a bit about Lou Peacham. That was Lou Peacham's idea. Yes. You guys remember, hi, Nardog. I'm Lou Peacham.
我也是。我要从宾夕法尼亚州莫尔文的奥利维亚开始。她说，我刚刚在听你们最近关于《研讨会》的那集，后稳定性（post-stabilities）部分稍微提到了路·皮查姆。那是路·皮查姆的主意。是的。你们大家还记得吗，嗨，纳德狗。我是路·皮查姆。
So guess what? Olivia wanted us to know that there is a post-stabilities. It's a real place. Yes. It's a very delicious Italian restaurant in Syracuse, New York. She said she has visited this restaurant many times with family and friends. And she did a little deep dive on post-stabilities. Are you ready?
所以你们猜怎么着？奥利维亚想让我们知道，确实有后稳定性（post-stabilities）这个地方。这是一个真实的地方。是的。这是纽约州雪城的一家非常美味的意大利餐厅。她说她和家人朋友多次光顾这家餐厅。她对后稳定性做了一次简短的深度解析。准备好了吗？
Be still, my heart. I know. Olivia, we are thrilled. She said it is located in Armory Square, which is a busy hub in Central Syracuse, known for its many diverse cafes and restaurants, as well as lively bars and nightlife along West Fayette and Walton streets. Post-stabilities, the restaurant has been there for 40 years and it opened in 1982 and it is the oldest active restaurant in downtown Syracuse.
我的心啊，别跳了。我知道。奥利维亚，我们太激动了。她说它位于军械广场（Armory Square），这是雪城中心一个繁华的枢纽，以其众多多元化的咖啡馆和餐厅，以及沿着西费耶特街和沃尔顿街的热闹酒吧和夜生活而闻名。后稳定性这家餐厅已经开了40年了，它于1982年开业，是雪城市中心现存最古老的营业餐厅。
Wow. Ready for this? Yes. It's been featured on the Food Network. What? Yes. They are well-known for their hot tomato oil. Hot tomato oil.
哇。准备好听这个了吗？是的。它曾登上过美食频道（Food Network）。什么？是的。它们以热番茄油闻名。热番茄油。
I know. They actually started packaging it and distributing it to grocery stores. How do you sell hot oil? I don't know, but you can buy it at Walmart. Oh, it's like spicy, like hot, like hot, spicy, hot, spicy, yeah. Oh, spicy. Yes. Oh, that makes sense.
我知道。它们实际上已经开始将其包装并分销到杂货店了。你怎么卖热油？我不知道，但你可以在沃尔玛买到。哦，它就像辣的，像辣的，像辣的，辣的，辣的，辣的，是的。哦，辣的。是的。哦，这就说得通了。
We caught up. What, are we buying oil in a thermostat? That's where my brain went. Well, you can buy it at Walmart and Amazon. And because of all the buzz the restaurant created, they opened a bakery right across the street. Sorry, I need you guys to know that Ainsley has ordered the oil. She said she's been to this place.
我们接上了。怎么，我们在恒温器里买油吗？我的大脑刚才飞到那去了。好吧，你可以在沃尔玛和亚马逊买到。由于这家餐厅引起了轰动，他们在街对面开了一家面包店。抱歉，我需要你们知道安妮斯利已经订购了这种油。她说她去过这个地方。
What? Ainsley, get her a microphone. You've been to post-stabilities and you've ordered the hot tomato oil? I've been to post-stabilities many times because I went to Syracuse University and that was a big deal for us to go off campus and go to post-stabilities. And that hot oil, I've had it delivered to me in Los Angeles. So it's spicy oil. It's spicy oil.
什么？安妮斯利，给她拿个麦克风。你去过后稳定性，而且你还订购过热番茄油？我去过后稳定性很多次，因为我上的是雪城大学，对我们来说，离开校园去后稳定性是一件大事。那种辣油，他们把它运到洛杉矶给我。所以它是辣油。它是辣油。
You can put it on pasta, but you can also dip bread in it. I love to dip bread and stuff. Yay. Well, maybe now it makes sense that one of our writers might have known about post-stabilities, which is why they made it Lou Peacham's business pitch. Olivia goes on to say, if you ever find yourself in Central New York, you've got to go. We've got to go. Thanks, Olivia.
你可以把它加在意大利面上，也可以用面包蘸着吃。我喜欢用面包蘸各种东西。太棒了。好吧，也许现在说得通了，为什么我们的编剧之一可能会知道后稳定性，这就是为什么他们把它成了路·皮查姆的商业推销。奥利维亚接着说，如果你发现自己身处纽约中部，你一定要去。我们得去。谢谢你，奥利维亚。
Find myself in Central New York. I'm going to purposely make a trip to Central New York just for post-stabilities. Well, maybe we'll go to a wedding there. That's what we need to do. We've got to bundle it. The wedding tour. Listen, if you're getting married and you're going to have your rehearsal dinner or maybe your reception at post-stabilities.
发现自己身处纽约中部。我得特意去一趟纽约中部，就为了后稳定性。好吧，也许我们会去那里参加婚礼。这就是我们需要做的。我们得把它们捆绑在一起。婚礼之旅。听着，如果你要结婚，并且打算在后稳定性举行彩排晚宴或者婚宴。
Let us know. Please, send us an invite. Well, I got a letter from Rachel in Burlington, Ontario, Canada, who has a tidbit also from the seminar episode. Do you remember the scene in the kitchen where Dwight is steeping Andy's tea? Yes. He's doing it incorrectly. Right.
让我们知道。请给我们发请柬。好吧，我收到了来自加拿大安大略省伯灵顿的瑞秋的信，她也有一个来自《研讨会》那一集的八卦。还记得厨房里德怀特泡安迪的茶那一幕吗？对。他泡错了。对。
But there was a mug and I tried to zoom in on it and I couldn't figure it out. It was really cute. Well, Rachel wrote in and said, I think that this mug is from Zumo's Cafe. I looked it up on the website and they have the same mugs as the one in this episode. It's a little cafe in Scranton. Oh, so I went to the Zumo's website and on their website, like Rachel said, they do feature these coffee mugs. The mugs actually say Electric City Roasting Company.
但那里有一个马克杯，我试图放大看，却没看出来。真的很可爱。好吧，瑞秋写信来说，我认为这个马克杯来自祖莫咖啡馆（Zumo's Cafe）。我在网站上查过，他们有和这一集里一模一样的马克杯。那是斯克兰顿的一家小咖啡馆。哦，所以我去了祖莫的网站，就像瑞秋说的那样，他们的网站上确实有这些咖啡马克杯。马克杯上实际上写着“电力城烘焙公司（Electric City Roasting Company）”。
It's all in the beans and they have a little mousse on them. And I found out that this coffee company was created by a woman in Scranton. And according to the website, the woman who started the company, her name is Mary. She had been living in San Francisco and had been getting all of this kind of, what would you call it, like artisan coffees. She moved back to Scranton and she felt like she couldn't find that artisan coffee anywhere in Scranton. So she made her own.
全靠豆子，上面还有一只小驯鹿（mousse）。我发现这家咖啡公司是由斯克兰顿的一位女性创立的。根据网站介绍，创立这家公司的女性名叫玛丽。她曾在旧金山生活，一直喝各种各样的，你叫它什么来着，比如手工咖啡。她搬回斯克兰顿，觉得在斯克兰顿到处都找不到那种手工咖啡。所以她自己做。
She made her own using a hot air gun and a funnel. The first blend that she created was called Blue Mousse. It was a big hit. So she retired from her job in banking and finance and she opened Zumo's Cafe in 2004. It is a combination coffee house, penny candy store and shoe cobbler. What? I couldn't get more information on the shoe cobbling part. We're all of a sudden in ye olde England.
她用热风枪和一个漏斗自己做。她创造的第一种混合咖啡叫做“蓝驯鹿（Blue Mousse）”。大受欢迎。于是她辞去了银行和金融界的工作，于2004年开办了祖莫咖啡馆。这是一个集咖啡馆、便士糖果店和修鞋匠于一体的店铺。什么？我找不到关于修鞋部分的更多信息。我们突然置身于老英格兰了。
I know. Sign me up. Is this a cuter place or what? I don't think so. So Mary went on to become a licensed Q grader of coffee. At the time in 2008, there were only 514 in the world. She was also one of the only female judges selected for the World Brewers Cup Competition in Vienna, Austria.
我知道。算我一个。还有比这更可爱的地儿吗？我不这么觉得。所以玛丽后来成为了一名有执照的Q级咖啡品鉴师。当时在2008年，全世界只有514位。她还是奥地利维也纳世界咖啡师大赛中仅有的几位女性评委之一。
I love the image of her with all those dudes in Austria and she's like, no, I'm here, guys. I know coffee. I had a glue gun, I had a funnel and I made it fucking happen. That's right. Today, the Electric City Roasting Company serves their coffee in cafes, grocery stores, hotels and directly to consumers on their website, electricscityroasting.com and get this. They have a special brew called Boom Roasted. Perfect.
我喜欢她和奥地利那些老兄在一起的画面，她就像是在说，不，我在这儿，伙计们。我懂咖啡。我有一把热风枪，我有一个漏斗，我他妈的把它做成了。没错。今天，“电力城烘焙公司”在咖啡馆、杂货店、酒店提供他们的咖啡，并直接在他们的网站 electricscityroasting.com 上向消费者出售，而且听着。他们有一种特别的冲泡咖啡叫“轰然烤熟（Boom Roasted）”。完美。
Here's a description. Quote, a tribute to the greatest television show from a northeastern Pennsylvania-based mid-sized coffee company with tasting notes of beers, beats and Battlestar Galactica. That's so cute. Boom Roasted is a wonderfully crafted dark roast with dark cocoa and nutty flavors. I really wanted to get us some, but I only discovered this two days ago and I couldn't get it in time, so I'll get us some Boom Roasted in the future. I love that story all because you couldn't make out a coffee mug.
这里有个描述。引述：“来自宾夕法尼亚州东北部一家中型咖啡公司对最伟大电视剧的致敬，带有啤酒、甜菜和太空堡垒卡拉狄加的风味。”太可爱了。“轰然烤熟”是一款精心制作的深度烘焙咖啡，带有浓郁的可可和坚果风味。我真的很想给我们弄一些，但我两天前才发现这个，来不及弄到，所以我以后会给我们弄点“轰然烤熟”来尝尝。我喜欢这个故事，就因为你们看不清一个马克杯。
In the background. Right? Love it. Well, we also got a delightful letter from Sierra in Elverson, Pennsylvania. It's about Michael's love of YouTube. Listen to this fun tidbit, Jenna. Sierra writes, here's why I think it's really cool whenever the office mentions YouTube throughout the show.
在背景里。对吧？太喜欢了。好吧，我们还收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州埃尔弗森的席亚拉的一封令人愉快的信。是关于迈克尔对YouTube的爱。听听这个有趣的八卦，珍娜。席亚拉写道，这就是为什么我认为《办公室》整部剧中只要提到YouTube就很酷的原因。
I come from a small town called Elverson in Pennsylvania. It's two hours south of Scranton. The high school that I attended was also the same high school as Chad Hurley. Chad Hurley is the creator of YouTube. Whoa. Yeah. She said our town is very small, so when people end up doing awesome things like creating one of the first and biggest media sharing platforms in the world, it sticks around for
我来自宾夕法尼亚州一个叫埃尔弗森的小镇。它在斯克兰顿以南两个小时车程的地方。我上的高中和查德·赫利（Chad Hurley）是同一所高中。查德·赫利是YouTube的创始人。哇。是的。她说我们镇非常小，所以当人们最终做出像创造世界上第一个也是最大的媒体分享平台之一这样了不起的事情时，它会流传很久。
a while. To be honest, people in our town still talk about this almost weekly. I like to think that the news of this spread to Scranton and the creators and stars of the show were just as tickled as we were. Yeah. She goes on to say, thanks for all of your great work on the podcast. I hope this makes you think of us whenever you hear Michael mention YouTube. P.S., I just think you should know that when Chad was trying to figure out the name for
老实说，我们镇上的人几乎每周还在谈论这个。我喜欢认为这个消息传到了斯克兰顿，剧集的创作者和明星们和我们一样兴奋。是的。她接着说，谢谢你们在播客中的出色工作。我希望每当你们听到迈克尔提到YouTube时，这能让你们想起我们。附言，我觉得你们应该知道，当查德试图为YouTube想名字时，他问我们的历史老师，他是否认为YouTube这个名字是个好名字。我的历史老师艾伦巴克先生说不。
YouTube, he asked our history teacher if he thought the name YouTube was a good one. My history teacher, Mr. Allenback, said no. Oh, no. And he really pushed for Chad to rename it, but Chad moved forward with the name YouTube anyways, and thus it was born. Wow. Isn't that so fun? That is so fun.
哦，不。他极力敦促查德改名，但查德还是用了YouTube这个名字，就这样它诞生了。哇。是不是很有趣？太有趣了。
Well, Jenna, I know a lot of folks have written in about what your panty lines rant meant to them and pockets and whatnot. I still get a lot of mail about Chunket. To refresh your memory when we were breaking down the episode, The Client, I described how Pam put Michael's pants in the trash, and you kind of have to hear Jenna's reaction in the moment to what I said. Let's play that clip. What's interesting to me is that this cold open implies that we have casual Fridays at
好吧，珍娜，我知道很多人写信来谈论你的内裤勒痕吐槽对他们的意义，还有口袋什么的。我仍然收到很多关于“块状物（Chunket）”的信。为了帮你们回忆一下，当我们在剖析《客户》那一集时，我描述了帕姆把迈克尔的裤子扔进垃圾桶，你对我说的话的即兴反应有点好笑。让我们播放那个片段。对我来说有趣的是，这个冷开场暗示我们在办公室有休闲星期五，但到目前为止，我们从未展示过休闲星期五，也没有引用过休闲星期五，而且我相信我们再也没有这样做过，尽管我们经常把剧集设定在星期五。不。这是唯一一次。我还说这个冷开场里有很棒的帕姆讽刺，因为你在最后做了什么？把牛仔裤扔（chunk）到了结果下面？是的，你只是，你把它们翻过来扔掉。
the office, but so far, we've never shown a casual Friday or referenced a casual Friday, and I believe we never do again, even though we very often have episodes set on a Friday. No. This is the one time. I said also there's some real great Pam Sass in this cold open because what do you do at the end? Chunk is jeans under the result? Yes, you just, you flip them over and you toss them.
我知道我在想什么。你一辈子都在说“chunk（块）”吗？是“chuck（扔）”。你把它们扔了。等等，不对。你一直吗？你一辈子都在说“chunk”吗？我想我，我想我，我想我说过你把它chunk了或者别的什么。
I know what I think. Have you been saying chunk your whole life? It's chuck. You chuck them. Wait, no. Have you? Have you been saying chunk for your whole life? I think I, I think I, I think I said you chunk it or something.
Chunk了？山姆，山姆，是chuck，对吧？是chuck。100%是chuck。有些人。又一个空气球。噢天哪。你扔你的威弗球吗？
Chunk it? Sam, Sam, it's chuck, right? It's chuck. It's 100% chuck. Some people. Another whiffle. Oh my God. Do you chunk your whiffle ball?
我chunk它。你chunk它。你狠狠地把它chunk向某人。噢天哪。我把眼镜摘了，因为我在哭。我在哭。我有太多。我chunk它。
I chunk it. You chunk it. You chunk it real hard at someone. Oh my God. I've taken my glasses off because I'm crying. I'm crying. I'm having so much. I chunk it.
你不能chunk它。哦天哪。哦天哪。所以人们仍在告诉我他们是“chunk它”派还是“chuck它”派。每当你是“chunk它”派时，真的让我的一天都变得美好了。这里有两个我想分享的。来自得克萨斯州沃思堡的贝姬·B写信说，我没有问题。我只是不得不告诉安吉拉，我刚才在看一个IG视频，一个男人从冰冻的池塘里救出一只小鹿，他用大锤砸开冰。一旦他把鹿抓在手里，他发现很难带着它和大锤一起走。在背景里，你能听到他的兄弟看到他很难两样都拿着，他的兄弟大喊：“把它chunk到这儿来！”我听到那个，立刻就得告诉你们。等等，等等。兄弟没有跑过去帮忙吗？兄弟就像是，把它chunk到这儿来。
You don't chunk it. Oh man. Oh Lord. So people are still letting me know if they are a chunk it or a chuck it person. And whenever you're a chunk it, it really makes my day. Here are two I want to share. Becky B. from Fort Worth, Texas wrote in and said, I don't have a question. I just had to tell Angela that I was just watching an IG video of a man rescuing a baby
但像老兄，放下相机帮帮我啊。我在从冰里救一只小鹿呢。就算那样。但我们别忘了这个事实。对不起。对不起。我保持专注。动词“chunk”被使用了。
deer from a frozen pond and he was using a sledgehammer to get through the ice. Once he had the deer in hand, he was having difficulty carrying it and the sledgehammer. In the background, you can hear his brother who sees that he's struggling to carry both and his brother yells, Chunk it up here. I heard that and immediately I had to tell you guys. Wait, wait. The brother didn't run in and help? The brother's like, Chunk it over here.
我们有一个“chunk it”。好的。有记录了。我们有了动词“chunk”的第二个用法。最近，你们中的许多人跟我分享了一篇文章，由一位ESPN专栏作家撰写。他的名字叫迈克·里斯（Mike Reese），他关于新英格兰爱国者队的四分卫马克·琼斯写了这样的话。我猜在一场非常令人沮丧的比赛后，马克被引述说：“显然，我只是让情绪占据了上风。
But like dude, put down the camera and help me. I'm rescuing a baby deer from the ice. There's that. But let's just not lose the fact. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I will stay focused. That the verb chunk was used.
我说的是在短传游戏中把它扔得更深。我得更好地执行那部分。但我觉得我们需要chunk传球（大步推进）。我大声喊出来是为了让大家振作起来。那是情绪。那是橄榄球。我对这项运动充满激情。”哇。
We have a chunk it. Okay. It's on record. We have a second use of the verb chunk. Recently, a bunch of you shared an article with me that was written by an ESPN staff writer. His name is Mike Reese and he wrote this about Mac Jones, the quarterback of the New England Patriots. I guess after a very frustrating game, Mac was quoted as saying this. Obviously, I just kind of let my emotions get to me.
谢谢你，马克和贝姬。我觉得我被看见了。安吉拉，我现在偶尔会口误说成“chunk it”。你告诉过我。你影响了我。当我们听那个片段，我问你是否chunk你的威弗球时，听起来并不违背常理。你还告诉我你丈夫听说过“chunk it”的用法。是的。
What I said was about throwing it deeper within the short game. I got to execute that part better. But I felt like we needed chunk plays. I shouted that out to kind of get everyone going. That's emotional. That's football. And I'm passionate about this game. Wow.
他在全国各地长大，但他的家人最终在得克萨斯州安顿下来。当他第一次去得克萨斯州时，他听到有人说“chunk it”，因为他一直说的是“chuck it”。他能够向我证实两者都在使用。非常感谢。而且意思是一样的。谢谢。我收到很多人的信，他们跟我分享当我说起我的焦虑时他们有多感激。还有我的社交焦虑。
Thank you, Mac and Becky. I feel seen. Angela, I occasionally slip and say chunk it now. You told me this. You have worn off on me. And when we were listening to that clip and I asked you if you chunk your waffle ball, it didn't sound wrong to me. You also told me your husband has heard of the use chunk it. Yes.
我们收到了一封来自荷兰诺克的信，他说，我19岁。我去年三月发现了你们的播客，一口气听完了所有剧集。我还听了你和爱丽丝·迈尔斯（Elise Myers）一起做的播客，你提到你饱受社交焦虑之苦。在之前的剧集里，你曾提到你以前有过焦虑，但我不知道你饱受社交焦虑之苦。这也是我一直在挣扎的事情。我觉得非常鼓舞人心的是，尽管你有社交焦虑，你还是选择了一个演员/聚光灯下的职业。我想知道你是否能多分享一点你的经历，关于焦虑过去和现在对你来说是什么样的。这是一个非常深思熟虑的问题。
He grew up all around the country, but his family eventually settled in Texas. And when he first got to Texas, he heard someone say chunk it because he had been saying chuck it. And he was able to confirm to me that both are used. Thank you very much. And mean the same thing. Thank you. And I get a lot of letters from people who share with me how much they appreciate when I talk about my anxiety. And my social anxiety.
是的。是的。这是非常普遍的事情。我有焦虑。我也是个内向的人。这看起来不是聚光灯下职业的好公式。我要说的是，你也热爱挑战。所以就像是你给自己设定了一个个人生活挑战。
And we got a letter from a nook in the Netherlands who said, I am 19 years old. I found your podcast last March and listened to all the episodes nonstop. I also just listened to the podcast you did with Elise Myers and you mentioned that you struggle with social anxiety. On previous episodes, you have mentioned that you had anxiety before, but I didn't know that you struggled with social anxiety. Something that I struggle with too. I find it so encouraging that even though you have social anxiety, you still chose an acting slash in the spotlight career. I was wondering if you could share a little bit more about your experiences of what anxiety was and still is like for you. It's a very thoughtful question.
有趣的是，我的治疗师不久前实际上说过，对于一个有焦虑问题的人来说，我选择了一个极具挑战性的职业。这也是那个有一年决定再也不用计算器、只自己做所有数学题的人。你热爱挑战。这是真的。我想我先给内向的人下个定义，因为我最近一直在查资料，因为我想区分我内向的自我和焦虑的自我。所以我们开始吧。首先，我了解到精神病学家卡尔·荣格在20世纪初提出了内向和外向的概念。确定你是否是内向的人最简单的方法是发现你如何给你的社交电池充电。
It is. It is. And this is such a common thing. I have anxiety. I am also an introvert. That does not seem like a good formula for a career in the spotlight. You know what I would say is that you also love a challenge. So it's like you gave yourself a personal life challenge.
所以内向者的社交欲望很低，往往更喜欢刺激最小的环境，他们向内寻求充电。外向者通过与他人在一起重新焕发活力。所以，例如，经过漫长的工作日后，你喜欢通过独处还是与朋友见面来充电？大家，我们对这个怎么看？我们小组里有什么人？我们是内向者还是外向者？对我来说内向。好的。内向，我喜欢独处。
It's interesting because my therapist a while back actually said that I picked a very challenging profession for a person with anxiety issues. This is also someone who decided one year to never use a calculator and only do all the math herself. You love a challenge. This is true. I thought I would start by defining an introvert because I was looking it up recently because I kind of wanted to differentiate between my introverted self and my anxious self. So here we go. First of all, I learned that psychiatrist Carl Jung developed the concepts of introversion and extroversion in the early 1900s. And the easiest way to determine if you are an introvert is by discovering how you recharge your social battery.
我不相信内向外向之分。我觉得每个人都在中间。哦，我喜欢这样。我喜欢卡西静静地坐在角落里。你在那边干嘛呢？我都不知道你在干嘛。她正在用电线捣鼓什么东西。我知道。看起来你在捣鼓电线。谁知道你在忙什么呢？你只是静静地坐在那里，然后我们把麦克风交给你，你就像是，我要对所有这些放屁（bulls***）。就像这种安静的力量。
So introverts have very low social desire and tend to prefer minimally stimulating environments and they go inward to recharge. Extroverts are re-energized from being around others. So for example, after a long work day, do you like to recharge by being alone or by meeting up with friends? Guys, where are we on this? What do we have in our group here? Do we have introverts or extroverts? Introvert for me. Okay. Introvert, I love being alone.
太棒了。我其实和卡西是一伙的。我喜欢独处，但我也希望在一天结束时和朋友见面，你知道的，聊聊我们的一天并一起发发牢骚。我的生活两样都需要。我明白了。好吧，让我看看这是否对我们有帮助。2011年，一些心理学家詹妮弗·格莱姆斯（Jennifer Grimes）、乔纳森·齐克（Jonathan Cheek）和朱莉·诺鲁姆（Julie Norum）将内向的性格细分为四种不同的类型。社交型内向者、思考型内向者、焦虑型内向者和克制型内向者。
I don't believe in introverts, extroverts. I think everyone's in the middle. Oh, I like that. I love when Cassie's just sitting in the corner. What are you doing over there? I don't even know what you're doing. She's doing something with some wires. I know. It looked like you were doing something with wires. Who knows what you're up to? You're just quietly sitting there and then we throw you on the mic and you're like, I'm gonna call bulls*** on all that. Just like this quiet power.
我读了这四种描述，我最认同社交型内向者。社交型内向者在完全独处时最开心，安妮斯利，我看着你呢，或者在安静地方的小群体里最开心。社交型内向者会高兴地独自去约会或度假。我不妨告诉你，我高中最后一年周五晚上都是一个人去看电影的。你还是很享受一个人去看电影。这是我们谈论过的事情，因为我永远不想那样做。就像，我永远不想一个人去看电影。我会独自在餐厅吃一顿饭。
It's so awesome. I'm actually with Cassie. I love being alone, but I also would love at the end of a day to meet up with friends and, you know, talk about our day and sort of commiserate. I need both in my life. I see. Well, let me see if this helps us. In 2011, some psychologists named Jennifer Grimes, Jonathan Cheek and Julie Norum broke down the introverted personality into four distinct types. The social introvert, the thinking introvert, the anxious introvert and the restrained introvert.
我有过——单人桌。我不得不习惯这一点，当我住在温哥华拍那部剧时，这对我也很难。我经常独自吃饭，起初我想，哦不，然后我开始喜欢它了。好吧，继续。思考型内向者在学习、阅读、学习、研究或调查时最平静。这有点像你。你喜欢在办公室里喝着早晨的咖啡，在那里你可以深入工作——
I read the four descriptions and I most identified with the social introvert. A social introvert is most happy in either complete solitude, Ainsley, I'm looking at you, or in small groups in subdued places. A social introvert will happily go on a solo date or vacation. I'll have you know, I was going to the movies by myself as a high school senior on a Friday night. You still enjoy going to the movies by yourself. It's something we've talked about because I would never want to do that. Like, I never want to go to the movie by myself. I will go eat a meal alone in a restaurant.
我告诉你们，我是所有这些内向者之一。克制型内向者行动较慢。他们渴望结构，在了解别人之前，他们对别人也有防备。我还在描述我自己吗？是的。我相信我是。最后，焦虑型内向者通常相当害羞和紧张，当他们遇到人时，有时会显得高度回避甚至粗鲁，因为社交互动让他们感到很不舒服
I had- Table for one. I had to get used to that and it was really hard for me when I was on that show in Vancouver. I ate alone a lot and at first I was like, oh no, and then I began to love it. All right, moving on. A thinking introvert are most at peace when they're studying, reading, learning, researching or investigating. That's kind of you. You love your morning cup of coffee in your office where you can dig into work and-
并且他们不惜一切代价想要避免社交互动。所以这些是我们的内向者列表，但这里有一些关于社交焦虑的内容。社交焦虑是一种疾病，你对社交互动有非理性的恐惧。有点倾向于那种焦虑型内向者。社交焦虑的症状包括对被评判的过度恐惧，不是轻微的恐惧。我希望每个人都明白，作为一名患有社交焦虑的人，这里的关键词是非理性的、过度的，还有对尴尬或羞辱的强烈担忧，或者担心冒犯他人。所以我要说的是，我可以去参加一个晚宴或进行一次社交互动，从纸面上看，一切都很顺利。
I'm telling you, I am every one of these introverts. A restrained introvert moves at a slower pace. They crave structure and they also have their guard up around others until they get to know them. Am I still describing myself? Yes. I believe I am. Finally, an anxious introvert are often quite shy and nervous and when they meet people, they can sometimes appear highly avoidant or even rude because social interactions make them so uncomfortable
我总是知道第二天从你那里得到什么。我接到语音信箱，你开始陷入精神螺旋。是的。这真的很神奇。实际上，我可以回家。我会在脑子里复盘每一个时刻。我会想到所有我搞砸了、让自己尴尬、冒犯了别人的方式，我的心会狂跳。有时我会失眠好几天。
and they want to avoid social interactions at all costs. So those are our list of introverts, but here's a little bit about social anxiety. Social anxiety is a disorder in which you have an irrational fear of social interactions. Kind of leans into that anxious introvert. Symptoms of social anxiety include excess fear of being judged, not mild fear. I want everyone to understand as a person with social anxiety, the key word here is irrational, excessive, also intense worry about embarrassment or humiliation or concern about offending another person. So I will say for me, I can go to a dinner party or a social interaction and on paper, everything went great.
并且他们不惜一切代价避免社交。所以这些是我们的内向者名单，但这里有一些关于社交焦虑的内容。社交焦虑是一种障碍，在这种障碍中，你对社交互动有着非理性的恐惧。有点倾向于那种焦虑的内向者。社交焦虑的症状包括对被评判的过度恐惧，而不是轻微的恐惧。我想让每个人都明白，作为一名患有社交焦虑的人，这里的关键词是不理性的、过度的，还有对尴尬或羞辱的强烈担忧，或者对冒犯他人的担忧。所以我要说的是，对我和我来说，我可以去参加一个晚宴或进行一次社交互动，从表面上看，一切都很顺利。
I always know what I'm going to get the next day with you. I get voicemail, where you spiral. Yeah. It's really amazing. Actually, I can come home. I will review every moment in my head. I will think of all the ways I messed up, embarrassed myself, offended someone, my heart will race. I will lose sleep sometimes for days.
我总是知道第二天从你这儿会得到什么。我会收到你的语音留言，你在里面陷入了情绪螺旋。是的。这真的很神奇。实际上，我可以回家。我会在脑海里回顾每一个瞬间。我会想到我所有搞砸了、让自己难堪、冒犯了别人的方式，我的心跳会加速。我有时会失眠好几天。
And this has been going on for me for as long as I can remember. I have always had this. I've gone to therapy for it, which has helped a ton. And I did that therapy before I became a professional actor. So I'm very grateful for that. I started therapy in my early 20s, but I have to say a nook in answer to your question. Acting has always been a little bit of an escape for me. In high school, like I said, I would avoid going to parties, but I loved being part of theater productions.
这种情况伴随了我很久，可以说是我记事起就有了。我一直为此寻求心理治疗，这对我帮助极大。在我成为专业演员之前我就开始做心理治疗了，对此我非常感激。我在二十岁出头时就开始了治疗，但我必须说，阿努克，为了回答你的问题，演戏对我来说一直算是一种逃避。正如我所说，在高中时，我会避免去参加派对，但我非常喜欢参与戏剧制作。
I loved the artistic community. I felt safe there. It's a very accepting group of folks. It is. And I often do well socially when there's a project involved. When we all have something we're working on or working toward. Because I do like people and I like being around people. And you're goal oriented, so it's like you have that common goal.
我喜欢那种艺术社区的氛围。我在那里感到安全。那是一个非常包容的群体。确实如此。而且当有项目参与时，我的社交通常表现得很好。当我们都有一个共同在做或者为之努力的事情时。因为我确实喜欢人群，也喜欢和大家在一起。而且你是有目标导向的，所以就好像你们有共同的目标。
So while I love acting, the part that has been hardest for me has been the public events like interviews or red carpets, things like that. I wrote in our book, The Office BFFs, that Melora, who plays Jan, was a really great mentor for me and how to navigate that part of the business with boundaries and self care. You know, it just requires a lot of thought, a lot of strategy for me. But yeah, this anxiety has never gone away. It just ebbs and flows. But here you are crushing it, lady. Here I am. Listen, like you said, I'm also very stubborn.
所以，虽然我热爱表演，但对我来说最难的部分一直是公开活动，比如采访、红毯之类的。我在我们的书《办公室闺蜜》中写过，饰演简的梅洛拉对我如何以边界感和自我关爱来应对这部分业务起到了很好的导师作用。你知道的，这对我来说需要大量的思考和策略。但是，是的，这种焦虑从未消失。它只是时起时伏。但你现在干得很棒，女士。我这不在这嘛。听着，就像你说的，我也非常顽固。
I don't like to be stopped. So I am a stubborn, social introvert with social anxiety and an actor and a podcaster and a mom and a friend. And I have the best BFF because having someone who will listen to me spiral the morning after a dinner party, that helps a lot. So thank you, lady, for being there for me. I always will. Now, Angela Anuk also had a question for you, which is this. I know that Angela has shared that she grew up in Indonesia. And as a TCK myself, I was wondering if she could share some of her experiences and difficulties in growing up there and what it was like returning to the U.S.
我不喜欢被阻拦。所以我是个顽固的、有社交焦虑的社交内向者，同时我还是一个演员、播客制作人、妈妈和朋友。我有最好的闺蜜，因为有一个人愿意在晚宴后的早晨听我情绪崩溃，这真的帮了大忙。所以谢谢你，女士，一直陪伴在我身边。我永远都会的。对了，安吉拉，阿努克还有一个问题想问你，是这样的。我知道安吉拉曾分享过她在印度尼西亚长大的经历。作为一个第三文化小孩，我想知道她能否分享一些在那里长大的经历和困难，以及回到美国后的感受，
and if and how it has affected her identity. Oh my goodness. Anuk, first of all, I think I went into comedy because we move so much and I was such a fish out of water growing up. And the quickest way for me to fit in was to make everyone laugh. But TCK means a third cultural kid and you grow up not in your home country. And you have a hard time kind of figuring out where you fit in because there's a huge part of me that loves and identifies with my childhood in Jakarta. And when I came to the U.S., I found it hard to fit in and find other people who had had an experience like that. But yet my family, my parents who were raising me in this other country had all of their traditions from their culture and where they grew up.
以及这是否影响了她的身份认同，又是如何影响的。噢天哪。阿努克，首先，我想我之所以选择喜剧，是因为我们搬家太频繁了，我成长过程中就像是一条离开水的鱼。而让我融入集体的最快方法就是逗大家笑。但第三文化小孩（TCK）意味着你并非在自己的祖国长大。你会很难搞清楚自己究竟属于哪里，因为我身上有很大一部分非常热爱并在认同我在雅加达的童年。当我来到美国时，我发现很难融入并找到有类似经历的人。然而我的家人，那些在异国抚养我的父母，却保留着他们文化和成长地的所有传统。
And when I would go to Texas and Louisiana in the summers and I wouldn't understand pop cultural references or I wouldn't understand colloquialisms or I felt like out of place there too. And it was sort of like, where do I fit in? And then you have this small group of people who also grew up like you that you really hold tight and dear. I am still friends with my friends that I grew up with in Jakarta. We all moved and got dispersed. And that's another thing because you don't have that constant touchstone of that neighborhood you always go home to, that corner store, that coffee shop. You grow up kind of displaced a little bit and it makes me crave roots and tradition. I get very attached to the smallest things about family tradition like, okay, it's Christmas Eve.
每当夏天我去得克萨斯州和路易斯安那州时，我都听不懂流行文化的梗，或者听不懂俗语，我也觉得自己在那儿格格不入。这就好像是在问，我到底属于哪里？然后你会发现，有一小群和你一样成长起来的人，你会紧紧抓住他们，倍加珍惜。我和我在雅加达一起长大的朋友至今仍是朋友。我们都搬过家，分散在各地。这也是另一个问题，因为你没有那种总是可以回家的街区、那个转角商店、那个咖啡馆作为持续的精神寄托。你的成长或多或少有点流离失所，这让我对根和传统产生了强烈的渴望。我对家庭传统的最小细节都非常依恋，比如，好吧，今天是平安夜。
We open one gift on Christmas Eve. And I remember one year my mom was like, what if we just open all of them? And I was like, no, because I needed some type of roots. But I am thankful for my childhood because I really believe and I know this that you could drop me anywhere and I will find a way to survive. I'll find my people. I'll find out what to do there and I'll be okay. I'm not fearful at all about new places and new experiences and new people and new cultures. I get excited about it.
我们在平安夜拆一件礼物。我记得有一年我妈妈说，要不我们把它们全拆了吧？我说，不行，因为我需要某种根基。但我很感激我的童年，因为我真的相信——我知道这一点——无论把我扔到哪里，我都能找到生存的办法。我会找到属于我的人。我会弄清楚该在那里做什么，我会没事的。对于新地方、新体验、新人和新文化，我一点也不害怕。我为此感到兴奋。
But yeah, Anook, I can definitely relate to that and ultimately now as an adult, I see it as a gift. But when I was a kid and we moved back in middle school, that was a tough time. And middle school is already tough. Oh my God, it's like, what? Am I wearing a training bra? What's happening? The most miserable couple of years of my life for middle school. I know. And I can still feel them.
但是，是的，阿努克，我绝对能感同身受，最终现在作为成年人，我把它看作是一份礼物。但当我还是个孩子、在初中搬回来时，那确实是一段艰难的时期。初中本来就很难熬。噢天哪，就好像是，什么？我在穿训练胸衣吗？发生什么事了？初中是我人生中最悲惨的几年。我懂。现在我还能感受到那种痛苦。
So for you to be also new, not just new school or new kid, but like new to being back in the country. Yeah. Wow. I know. I would say things too and people would be like, what are you talking about all the time? But Anook, thanks so much for asking about that. It's a part of my childhood that I just treasure. As an adult, I really have seen it now to be such a gift that I had that I grew up in a different country.
所以对你来说，也是个新人，不仅是新学校或新孩子，而且是刚回到国内。对。哇。我懂。我也会说一些话，然后大家总是会问，你在说什么呢？但阿努克，非常感谢你问起这个。这是我童年中非常珍视的一部分。作为一个成年人，我真的认为曾在另一个国家长大是一份如此珍贵的礼物。
I have such great perspective and appreciation for sort of a global view of the world that we're all in this together. We really are. So I love it when people reach out to me about that. I also got a letter from Sarah who is living near my old school in South Jakarta. No way. Yeah. She's living near GIS, which is where I went to school. And she sent me the most beautiful batik skirt.
我对世界有一种宏观的视角，对“我们都在同一条船上”这一点有着极好的开阔视野和感激之情。我们真的在一起。所以我很喜欢人们为此联系我。我还收到了一封来自萨拉的信，她住在南雅加达我的老学校附近。不会吧。对。她住在GIS附近，那是我上过学的地方。她寄给我一条最美丽的蜡染半身裙。
Sarah, I'm totally going to wear it. It's so beautiful. I'll put a photo of it in stories. Here's the letter she wrote, dear office ladies, my family and I have been a huge office fans. And so when your podcast came out, I was thrilled. And imagine our delight to find out that Angela went to school at GIS. We have lived down the street from that school for the last five years. And I just had to reach out and send you guys a few goodies, a traditional batik skirt and Javanese coffee from Luwak.
萨拉，我绝对要穿它。太漂亮了。我会把它的照片发在动态里。以下是她写的信：亲爱的办公室女士们，我和我的家人一直是《办公室》的超级粉丝。所以当你们的播客上线时，我欣喜若狂。可以想象当我们发现安吉拉曾就读于GIS时，我们有多高兴。过去五年里，我们一直住在离那所学校一条街的地方。我不得不联系你们，送你们一些小礼物，一条传统的蜡染裙和来自猫屎咖啡的爪哇咖啡。
Jenna, you would love this coffee. You know I love a coffee. I know. Please keep up the great work on the podcast. So great to enjoy a bit of home when abroad with much love, Sarah. Sarah, thank you. I just said, thank you, Sarah. Well, I love when people send us things, Angela, and people get real creative in the things they send.
珍娜，你一定会喜欢这款咖啡。你知道我喜欢咖啡。我知道。请继续在播客中做出色作品。在海外能享受到一点家的感觉真是太棒了，祝一切都好，萨拉。萨拉，谢谢你。我刚才说，谢谢你，萨拉。哦，安吉拉，我很喜欢大家给我们寄东西，大家在寄的东西上真的很有创意。
I got a letter from Chris S. in Knoxville, Tennessee, who remembered when we talked about our love of wheel of four. Oh, my grandmother's favorite show. Chris emailed Vanna White and told her that we were fans. I don't know how he had her email, but somehow he got her to send us each personalized photos autographed by Vanna White and Patsy Jack. Here they are. You're kidding me. No. Somewhere my grandmother in heaven is smiling.
我收到了一封来自田纳西州诺克斯维尔的克里斯·S.的信，他记得我们曾谈起对《命运轮盘》的热爱。噢，我祖母最喜欢的节目。克里斯给万娜·怀特发了电子邮件，说我们是粉丝。我不知道他是怎么弄到她的电子邮件的，但不知怎的，他让万娜·怀特和帕西·杰克给我们每人寄了亲笔签名的个性化照片。它们就在这。你在开玩笑吧。没有。我在天国的祖母某处正笑着呢。
Wait, I have to see this. Here, there's one for each of us. There it is. Two Angela Hart Vanna White. Oh, my God. And Patsy Jack. And Patsy Jack. Look how glamorous.
等等，我得看看这个。给，我们每人一张。就在这。致安吉拉，署名万娜·怀特。噢，天哪。还有帕西·杰克。还有帕西·杰克。看她多迷人。
Look how glamorous she looks. It's a great photo. Oh, my goodness. That is amazing. Angela, when we get our new studio space. That's going up on the wall. We're going to have the best autograph wall thanks to Sam and Chris. And my God, if we could get a personalized autograph from Keanu.
看她看起来多迷人。这是一张很棒的照片。噢，天哪。太棒了。安吉拉，当我们拥有新的工作室空间时。那要挂在墙上。多亏了萨姆和克里斯，我们将拥有最棒的签名墙。天哪，如果我们能得到基努的亲笔签名就好了。
Don't say it. Don't even say it. From Keanu. Don't even say it. We'll be complete. Keanu, please come visit us at our new space. Keanu, it's going to be a great space. And you'll love it.
别说。甚至别说。来自基努的。别说。那就圆满了。基努，请来我们的新空间参观吧。基努，这会是一个很棒的空间。你会喜欢的。
Keanu, please. We're just saying. We also love getting your art. So many of you guys have painted and drawn pictures for us. That's going to go on our wall in our new space. I want to give a shout out to the coolest art sent in by UnluckyPress.com. It's so great. It's okay, guys.
基努，求你了。我们只是说说而已。我们也喜欢收到你们的艺术作品。你们中的很多人都为我们画了画。这些都会挂在我们新空间的新墙上。我要感谢 UnluckyPress.com 寄来的最酷的艺术品。太棒了。没事的，伙计们。
It's amazing. The Charles Schultz Peanuts Gang meets Cafe Disco. It's the whole kind of hangout down in Cafe Disco portrayed by the Peanuts characters. But it's like a Peanuts Pam and a Peanuts Angela. Yes, exactly. Right? Yes. It's so cute.
太棒了。查尔斯·舒尔茨的《花生漫画》帮遇见了迪斯科咖啡厅。这是由《花生漫画》角色们演绎的迪斯科咖啡厅里的各种聚会场景。但它就像一个花生漫画版的帕姆和一个花生漫画版的安吉拉。是的，完全没错。对吧？是的。太可爱了。
It's so stinking cute. We're going to put it in our Instagram. I love it so much. I have another fun thing to share. What is it? I have a business card from Catherine in Lincoln, Nebraska. And she put a business card inside with a note. I am fascinated by her business card.
简直可爱得要命。我们要把它发到我们的 Instagram 上。我太喜欢了。我还有一件有趣的事情要分享。是什么？我有来自内布拉斯加州林肯市凯瑟琳的名片。她在里面放了一张名片并附带了一张便条。我被她的名片迷住了。
What is it? I did a deep dive on her business card. What is it? It said, quote, blank journals and more. Lady, she makes her own journals. You're kidding me. I found a write up about Catherine and here's something she said. Book binding has become my passion out of a love for beautiful and unique papers, leathers,
是什么？我深入研究了她的名片。是什么？上面写着，引述一下，“空白日记本及其他”。女士，她自己制作日记本。你在逗我吗？我找到了关于凯瑟琳的一篇报道，这是她说的话：出于对美丽而独特的纸张、皮革、
beads and other found objects that I collect from my everyday life. By combining these different elements, I create each book as an individual piece of art. They each have a title, a theme and a voice. Each book is full of blank pages for use as a journal, a photo album, a sketchbook are simply a personal place to put thoughts. She has a studio in her home where she fulfills custom orders and she currently teaches and demonstrates paper arts at various locations. Catherine, I found you on Etsy.
珠子以及我从日常生活中收集的其他现成物品的热爱，书籍装订已经成为了我的激情所在。通过将这些不同的元素结合起来，我将每一本书都创作成为一件独立的艺术品。它们各自都有一个标题、一个主题和一个声音。每本书都充满了空白页，可用作日记、相册、素托本，或者仅仅是存放想法的私人空间。她在自己家里有一个工作室，用来完成定制订单，她目前还在各地教授和演示纸艺。凯瑟琳，我在 Etsy 上找到你了。
Your journals are beautiful. I saw you're taking some time off, but when you're back, I will be ordering one. Angela. Yes, you will be. I know. I can't wait to write ridiculously stupid things in it, but it will be mine and it will be beautiful. Well guys, thank you for all of your mail.
你的日记本太美了。我看到你在休假，但当你回来时，我会订购一本的。安吉拉。是的，你一定会。我知道。我迫不及待地想在里面写一些荒谬愚蠢的东西，但它将属于我，而且它会很美。好了，伙计们，谢谢你们所有的信件。
I really felt like I spent the last few days with you guys, just hearing your voices, hearing your stories and it really built me up, so thank you so much. We hope you have a wonderful holiday and a happy new year. We will be back on January 4th with Billie Eilish. Happy holidays you guys. Bye. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
我真的觉得过去几天我和你们在一起，听着你们的声音，听着你们的故事，这真的让我振作起来，所以非常感谢你们。我们希望你们有一个美好的假期和快乐的新年。我们将在1月4日带着比利·艾利什回归。节日快乐，伙计们。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听办公室女士。
Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的声音工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是里德·布拉顿的《橡皮树》。要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月 Stitcher Premium，请使用代码 Office。本集尚无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。